Lohenlasen
0w größer kekw muss einfach noch mal gesagt werden
ne mir ist grad nix bescheuteres eingefallen zum start eigentlich ist mir gar nix zum start eingefallen ich hab irgendwas gesagt
aber so wie man das hier macht auf twitch fehlt einfach irgendeinen schwachsinn und die leute gucken
einem glücklicherweise bald zu leute ich sehe grad ich habe 18.000 follower geknackt auf twitch das
ist ja warum ist nimmer sound so laut ich habe auf 50 prozent gestellt das ist fail sagt
kann sich wieder nicht entscheiden mit der lautstärke ist
nein nein das stimmt nicht genau umgedreht nicht so nice
übrigens hab gestern im stream geguckt und da hat einer eine wirklich exzellente frage
gestellt und zwar warum gibt es nur pepega als emote warum gibt es nicht paypega für
irgendwelche pay to win geschichte das müsste es doch eigentlich auch geben dass da noch keiner
auf die idee gekommen ist paypega als emote zu machen das sollte man es gibt es gibt ja das
pepega ding mit kreditkarte warum heißt das nicht paypega ja fragen fragen also wenn paypega
ist zum beispiel windows 11 ist paypega ich mache einfach den windows ich mache einfach
des windows monka es rein bei mir ein channel das heißt dann wo paypega 0 0 0 0 übrigens ich
habe ich habe die woche jetzt die news gelesen bei golem und golem hat mich hart getriggert
hier was habe ich da gerade gelesen windows 2021 kostet mir ja das ist mir sowas von
egal gibt es wirklich noch jemand der windows 2000 also der nicht office der office freiwillig
verwendet ja ich weiß diese ganzen sekretärinnen dieser welt verwenden office 2021 aber wer
ist wer ist wirklich noch wer befindet sich also wer benutzt das wirklich freiwillig ich
also generell für mich haben office office sweeten also office produkte keine daseinsberechtigung
das einzige die einzige wisst ihr was die einzige anwendung ist wo ich verstehe dass
man die verwendet wo ich auch einen gewissen mehrwert drin sehe die einzige anwendung aus
office ist aber so one now zähle ich nicht so office und outlook ist ja auch im prinzip
was eigentlich die einzige anwendung ist excel excel ist die einzige anwendung die irgendwie
daseinsberechtigung hat excel ist die programmierumgebung der sekretärinnen dieser welt oder sekretäre
sekretärinnen müssten heutzutage sagen wenn man da ganz korrekt ist
xs halbauf sekunde ich muss mal kurz mein nas putzen ich glaube das wollte ich mit mikrofon
anmachen.
Nein, wollt ihr nicht.
So, exellent, da bin ich wieder.
So, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, ich wollt mich ja gar nicht so sehr über Office.
Alter, Corona zahlt allen wieder hier.
Okay, jetzt aber, jetzt aber.
Ich wollt mich ja eigentlich gar nicht über Office aufregen.
Jaja, wir benutzen auch noch Office.
Was sollen sie sonst nutzen?
Kein, gar kein Office.
Office ist komplett overrated.
Du brauchst eigentlich Office für nix.
Ich schreib auch Dokumente und formatiere sie, also am Ende exporte sie als HTML, ohne
dass ich da für irgendwelchen Office-Shit verwende.
Übrigens, also ich wollt mich gar nicht über Office aufregen.
Golem hat mich übelst getriggert diese Woche und zwar, die haben irgendwas geschrieben
zu New World.
Hier, die haben geschrieben, als ich diese Überschrift gelesen hab, hab ich mich mega
aufgeregt.
Also, für meine Verhältnisse mega aufgeregt.
Also, eigentlich ist es bis nach wie vor egal, aber es hat mich aufgeregt, dass sie so was
geschrieben haben.
New World zerstört jetzt nicht nur GeForce, das ist einfach kompletter Schwachsinn.
Das ist, jetzt fangen die mit diesem Mist auch schon an, das ist kompletter Schwachsinn.
New World zerstört keine Grafikkarten.
Die Hersteller bauen minderwertige Hardware, das liegt doch nicht an New World.
Was soll das, was soll dieser Blödsinn?
Spielst du den New World Wartenschlangensimulator?
Nein, ich spiel New World gar nicht.
Und in drei Monaten werden sich die Leute, ich sag's euch jetzt, wie es ist mit New World,
in drei Monaten werden sich die Leute zurücksehnen nach der Zeit, wo sie in Warteschlangen gesessen
haben.
Weil die Server haben bloß 2000 Spieler und in drei, vier Monaten sind 60, 70% der Spieler
weg.
Was bleiben wird bei New World, da bin ich mir relativ sicher, das sind halt die Leute,
die das Guilden-Faction-basierte PvP mögen, aber das sind die meisten Leute, die spielen
nicht.
Die wissen sie bloß doch nicht.
Werden wir sehen, werden wir sehen, also ich tippe da ganz stark drauf, mal gucken, vielleicht
liege ich auch komplett falsch.
Aber ich hab da ganz gutes Gefühl für mittlerweile, normalerweise.
So, was die hier für einen Stuss schreiben, ist totaler Blödsinn, New World zerstört
keine Grafikkarten.
Was sich ja auch rausgestellt hat in der Alpha ist, dass die Leute in der Warteschlange gehängt
haben, dass dort die FPS nicht gecapped waren und deswegen die Grafikkarten überhitzt sind,
das liegt aber am System, am Aufbau bzw. an der schlechten Qualität der Grafikkarten,
das macht es nicht kaputt.
Okay, Nachtrag, oh man, die bleiben da wirklich bei.
By the way, wenn ich diese Sache hier sehe, New World, der New World Grafikstyle, das
ist eines der, okay wie umschreibe ich das jetzt am besten, mir fällt da kein richtiges
Wort für einen, ist so am meisten gewollt und nicht gekonnt, den ich in letzter Zeit
in so einem AAA-Game gesehen habe, es ist nicht wirklich schlecht, also du merkst schon,
dass die Leute, ich weiß jetzt wie es aussieht, ich weiß wie der New World, jetzt fällt es
mir ein, jetzt fällt es mir ein, der New World Grafikstyle sieht ein bisschen so aus, als
hat jemand sich fünf verschiedene Assetpacks gekauft, die ungefähr thematisch in die gleiche
Richtung gehen, hat aber Mittelalter und Piraten-Settings gemischt dabei, das so sieht New World aus,
als hätten sie fünf verschiedene Assetpacks gekauft, die ungefähr in die gleiche Richtung
gehen und in das gleiche Game gepackt, weil die haben das selbst gemacht, aber es sieht
einfach so unpassend aus, das sieht irgendwie noch nach Mittelalter aus, das sieht nach,
ich weiß es nicht aus, Schneewittchen und die sieben Zwerge, keine Ahnung und das sieht
so ein bisschen eher nach Pirate-Kolonialzeit, wie auch immer aus, das schmerzt mir immer
so richtig, wenn ich New World Gameplay sehe, dass das so unpassend aussieht zusammen, die
Zauberanimation, ja gut, das stimmt, aber das finde ich auch legitim, weil in New World
ist teilweise relativ viel los, Open World, PvP-technisch und wenn da alle Zauber super
krasse Animationen hätten, würden sie gar nicht mehr durchblicken, aber es ist einfach
Schwachsinn, das New World Gameplay, aber guck mal, was sagen denn die Kommentare dazu?
Okay, das Forum weiß Bescheid, das Forum weiß Bescheid, also was sagt das Forum?
Guck mal, hier drei Seiten Thread, natürlich, egal was ein Spiel macht, darf die Grafikkarte
wenn das, natürlich, da hat er Recht, richtig, genau so ist es, genau so ist es, wenn du,
wenn du als Hersteller, und das ist ja nicht so, als würde New World da irgendwelche speziellen
Dinge machen, gehen wir davon aus, wenn du als Hersteller die Schnittstellen verwendest,
die dir die Hersteller anbieten, was im Endeffekt irgendwas ist, von DirectX bis Vulcan bis
Wind Wings, OpenGL, was auch immer, was sag ich, aus Mantle geworden, Mantle ist jetzt
glaube ich in Vulcan mit drin, na egal, und dann kannst du die Grafikkarte nicht kaputt
machen, es sei denn der Hersteller hat's verschissen und das ist in diesem Fall so, naja, das hat
mich wirklich hart, hart getriggert, als ich das gelesen habe, echt, da kann ich mich überhaupt
nicht mehr dran erinnern, stand das in der Alpha auch da, das ist aber so eine richtige
Kokona Warnung, ich kann mich noch an meine alte Microsoft Office Keyboard, ich hatte
mal so ein richtig hettes sowas hier in der Richtung, das da nur in schwarz, Office Keyboard,
das hatte ich früher mal nur in schwarz, so das hier, genau das, genau das, das war eines
der ersten USB Tastaturen, die so jemand, und wenn man das umgedreht hat, diese Tastaturen,
übrigens die fand ich richtig cool, die Tastaturen, die hatte ich, guck mal, das kostet nicht
viel, die hatte ich bestimmt 10 Jahre lang oder so, die fand ich richtig geil, auch das
war auch, ich fand es auch relativ ergonomisch mit dieser Handauflage, leider war das so
eine ganz normale Billigtastature drunter, die nach ein paar Jahren so krass gewobbelt
hat, dass du, also hier auf so einer halbmechanischen kannst du wirklich schnell spammen, das ging
oft, das ging oft gar nicht richtig, du hast da teilweise 150 Millisekunden Tastendruck
und sowas, naja, zumindest hinten drauf auf dieser Tastatur stand so der typische Kokona
Hinweis, das Verwenden, also Achtung, das Verwenden einer Tastatur kann zu schweren gesundheitlichen
Schäden führen, das ist halt so die typische Kokona Anweisung, wie auch immer, also das
ist so eine typische Ami Anweisung, weil wenn man die Tastatur nimmt und damit andere Leute
quasi irgendwie auf den Kopf schlägt, dann kann die zu schweren gesundheitlichen Schäden
führen, wenn man eine Tastatur zudem verwendet, wie sie da ist, an Rechner angeschlossen
zu werden und zu tippen, dann wird es schwierig mit schweren gesundheitlichen Schäden, aber
bei den Amis ist das alles möglich, ich mein, bei den Amis weißt du nie, vielleicht nehmen
die die auch mit auf irgendeine firing range, wie heißt das, firing range, was auch immer,
und gucken ob man durchschießen kann und stellen sich dabei dahinter und lassen sich
dann erschießen oder so und sagen, ich dachte die Tastatur blockt das, also bei den Amis
bin ich mir da bei nichts, da halte ich alles für möglich, die kriegen das irgendwie hin,
ja gut, die schlagen halt einfach ihren Kopf drauf, ach was auch immer, das ist totaler
Blödsinn, hey Max, ich will später einmal Softwareentwickler werden, exzellent, exzellent,
also habe ich bei mehreren Ausbildungen beworben, bei der Fachinformatiker Anwägungsentwicklung
leider nur Absagen, haben die gesagt, warum oder war da nur diese übliche Geschichte,
viel Glück auf ihrem weiteren Weg, bei der Fachinformatiker Systemintegration eine Zusage,
sind die beiden aus, nein die sind nicht, also kommt auf den Betrieb an, von der Berufsschule
und von der Prüfung sind die nicht großartig unterschiedlich, im Betrieb wird schon ziemlich
unterschiedlich sein, was du machst, je nach Betrieb, wohnen sich dann überhaupt eine
Fachinformatiker Systemintegration Ausbildung zu machen oder soll ich lieber bis nächstes
Jahr, also wenn ich eine Zusage hätte, also ich würde es von zwei Dingen abmachen, taugt
der Betrieb, den ich hier eine Zusage habe, also wenn dir der Betrieb, also wenn du jetzt
nicht sagst, alter so ein Kackler, dann würde ich auf gar keinen Fall hin, dann würde ich
die Ausbildung machen, ich würde also würde ich die Ausbildung anfangen, die müsste doch
jetzt auch losgehen, die hätte doch jetzt eigentlich anfangen müssen, wann soll die
denn losgehen, was ist denn, ist denen ein Azubi vielleicht abgesprungen den hier, weil
normalerweise haben die alle schon angefangen oder ist das eine Ausbildung für 2022 jetzt
schon, das müsstest du mal schreiben, zumindest, also ich, also wenn ich den Betrieb einigermaßen
ok finden würde, würde ich da anfangen, denn man muss sagen, in der Berufsschule als
auch von der Prüfung ist es nicht so ein großer und eigentlich gar kein, also ein minimaler
Unterschied, ja du hast in der Abschlussprüfung, du hast ein Teil, ist ein bisschen unterschiedlich
für Anwendungsanwickler, Systemintegration und auch in der Berufsschule ist es nicht
so ein wahnsinniger Unterschied, du hast die Lernfelder ein bisschen anders gewichtet,
aber im Prinzip ist es der gleiche Shit, so und nichtsdestotrotz kannst du, nachdem du
eine Fachinformatik, Systemintegration, Ausbildung gemacht hast, wenn du gut programmieren kannst
oder wenn du dich in irgendeinem Bereich auskennst, den man braucht bei Softwareentwicklung, kannst
du das auch ohne Probleme später machen, das meiste lernt man ja eh nicht in der Ausbildung,
wenn es rein um, sagen wir so Programmiergrundlagen geht, zumindest ich, also wie gesagt, ich
konnte schon lange vor meiner Ausbildung programmieren und die Kombination aus beidem hat es im Endeffekt
auch dazu geführt, dass ich das mache, was ich mache, also ich habe bei einem Provider
Fachinformatiker Systemintegration gelernt, ich habe mich schon immer für Softwareentwicklung
programmieren interessiert und im Endeffekt bin ich deswegen auch so in diese Devops Schiene
reingerutscht und leider mache ich heutzutage quasi die Hälfte meiner Zeit irgendwelche
sinnlosen Code Reviews, aber ich kann in letzter Zeit ja glücklicherweise wieder mehr programmieren
selbst, aber das eine oder das andere, das zementiert nicht für immer deinen beruflichen
Weg so, Hullstack, Def bis Sack of Ops, genau, so siehts aus, so siehts aus und Agil, Agile,
Agile musst du sein, Massive Agile, so mal gucken, ob er jetzt darauf geantwortet hat,
M-X-X-A-R-X, ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht, aber danke für den Prime Sub,
Huge Subscription, nice, naja, so, ich habe ein Problem Leute, mein Browser war der Meinung,
beziehungsweise mein YouTube war der Meinung, es hat alle Cookies vergessen und immer wenn
ich Google aufmache bekomme ich jetzt sinnlose random allgemeine Empfehlungen, warum ich hier
halbwegs sinnvolle Empfehlungen kriege liegt daran, weil ich vorhin schon mal ein paar
Videos aufgemacht habe, wie wir letzte Woche geguckt haben und danach noch ein paar andere
Videos aufgemacht haben, dass es so ungefähr wieder halbwegs matcht, was die uns empfehlen
sollen, nur, nur eine Sache irritiert mich bei, bei YouTube, das kriege ich auch auf
meinem, alter ich hab noch irgendwas, irgendwas im Hals, ich kriege auch auf meinem normalen
YouTube mittlerweile relativ viel Weep Zeug empfohlen, ich weiß nicht genau warum, ich
gucke eigentlich so gut wie nix an Anime oder sonst was und mittlerweile ist, also Weep Nation
ist auf YouTube hier angesagt, guck mal ich krieg sogar Videos hier empfohlen von irgendwelchen,
von irgendwelchen Battlefield, ich wusste bis jetzt nicht mal, dass es Battlefield VTuber
gibt, es gibt Battlefield VTuber, kann man sich das denn vorstellen?
Es ist Wahnsinn, naja, ich habe 4 oder 5 Videos gebucht, aber vieles davon ist nicht IT,
wir gucken nur IT Stels, YouTube noch eine Chance, mein Bein juckt, warum juckt mein
Bein?
Na gut, besser als wenn es nix mehr macht, also wenn es nicht juckt wäre auch nicht gut,
Docker Kurs in 2 Stunden, ja genau, ich glaube das ist das beste Aufwachprogramm, wir gucken
uns in 2 Stunden Docker Kurs an, easy, dann sei der bestimmt alle wahnsinnig wach danach,
vergessen den Incognito Modus auszumachen, das ist nicht Incognito Modus, aber 1,5 Millionen
Views, ey die machen ganz gute Videos, die machen ganz gute Videos, also ich kann das
verstehen und Docker ist ja nach wie vor eines der gefragtesten Sachen, gerade weil es auf
jeden Fall von Vorteil ist, sei es wenn man jetzt in Richtung irgendwie, wie heißt das
neue CoreOS, Flatcar heißt es jetzt glaube ich, oder in irgendwelche Containerbetriebssysteme
geht oder sei es irgendwelche Kubernetes Geschichten, da ist es Docker Vorkenntnis auf jeden Fall
äußerst praktisch, ich finde es by the way, ich finde es immer noch die schlechteste Benahmung,
ich finde es immer noch die schlechteste Produktbenahmung aller Zeiten, Flatcar Linux, das klingt so
nichtsragend und CoreOS hat irgendwie noch Sinn ergeben, ich meine es ist flach, ich
verstehe schon dünn und so, aber das ist so drum die Benahmung einfach nur, ich weiß
nicht, ich kann damit nichts anfangen, also YouTube schafft es nicht uns sinnvolle Sachen
zu empfehlen, deswegen lassen wir uns jetzt eine Runde von LevelCapture Baben würde ich
sagen, was richtig heißt ist Döcker, warum nicht, Döcker, Döcker, Döcker das hört
sich fast an, wirklich wie irgendein türkisches, wie irgendein türkischer Nachtisch oder so,
hast du heute schon Döcker gegessen, Döcker mit allem wie immer, ne ich finde das hört
sich irgendwie wie ein Nachtisch an, schon Döcker gemacht, do you really find, Stackoverflow
sells, ne nicht Stackoverflow, Liveoverflow, ja Overflow war richtig, oh das ist glaube
ich, das ist glaube ich Bigbrain Content, der ist zu high IQ für jetzt gleich zum Einstieg,
was ist das, ah, ja ich finde das hört sich wirklich ähnlich an, ich habe immer noch
was im Hals, ich weiß auch nicht woran das liegt, Monke S, aber ich hatte auch vor 2
Wochen richtig Hals weh, ist aber schon wieder besser, so wir lassen uns jetzt eine Runde,
der Chat wieder, wir lassen uns jetzt eine, okay, ich gebe da schnell drüber, wir gucken
uns jetzt nicht 19 Minuten an, ich wette mit euch, das meiste braucht kein Mensch, diese
Videos, diese Videos sind immer so richtig, so richtig gebated sind diese Videos, so richtig,
also schauen wir mal, ah, okay, wir haben noch nicht mal Timestamps, what the fuck, was
ist, okay wir skippen das jetzt, wir skippen das jetzt vor, was braucht man, Werbung, okay
wo gehts los, hier gehts los, eh, OMFG, hier gehts los, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh,
OMFG, huge hacks, okay, ach so, ja, das kenne ich, das kenne ich, man kann das verschieben
wenn man öfters klickt, hallo, das ist kein free program, Windows Update ist dabei, GPU-Z,
GPU-Z brauchen 99% der User schonmal nicht, es mag ganz praktisch sein, wenn man irgendwelche
Hardware öfters, öfters ausprobiert, übertaktet, nachgucken will, 99% der User braucht garantiert
nicht GPU-Z, oder GPU-Z wahrscheinlich, Z, Z, so was wie Dates, vielleicht ist es auch
GPU-Z, okay, brauchen wir nicht, der ist wirklich praktisch, da hat er recht, das ist wirklich
praktisch, aber wahrscheinlich wollen sich das 99% der User auch nicht angucken, das
ist aber wirklich praktisch, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, wo wir unsere eigene
GPU-Temperatur-Overlay programmiert haben, ich glaube, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
ich glaube, dafür haben wir die CPU-ID oder HW-Monitor-Library verwendet, die native Windows
HW-Monitor-Library, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau, ich glaub schon, ich glaub die haben
auch eine Library, dass man den Kram abfragen kann aus seinem eigenen Kram, aus seinem eigenen
Programm, wir haben mal so einen GPU-Temperatur-Overlay gebastelt, nicht weil man das braucht,
sondern einfach weil ich wissen wollte, wie das funktioniert, ja, okay, das ist tatsächlich
äußerst praktisch, okay, schon wieder, schon wieder, ja, CPU-Overclocking ist etwas, was
die meisten Leute umsetzen, okay, das brauchen die meisten Leute auch nicht, was haben wir
sonst noch zu bieten, Afterburner, das ist wirklich praktisch, Afterburner ist tatsächlich
richtig, richtig praktisch, das ist, finde ich, hat das beste Overlay, das beste Overlay,
also mittlerweile benutzt sich nur das eingebaute Nvidia, aber das hat mit, finde ich, mit das
beste Overlay, wenn man wirklich wissen will, in-game, was abgeht mit seiner Hardware, das
finde ich wirklich praktisch und auch wenn man Übertaktung-Stells macht, ist Afterburner
wirklich nice, ja, da würde ich ihm recht geben, aber sag mal, das ist wieder so ein
Programm, was 90% der Leute nicht brauchen, so, next, oh fuck, das gibt's noch, das verwenden
noch Leute, krasser Shit, wusste ich gar nicht, okay, das war jetzt, das war jetzt,
oh, also, wie soll ich sagen, also 20 Minuten Video für drei Programme, die im Prinzip
99% der User auf dem Desktop nicht brauchen, das ist eher für die Overclocker-Fraktion,
ja, das kann man sich auf jeden Fall darüber streiten, ob das wirklich jeder braucht,
warum möchtet ihr mir das immer, warum möchtet ihr mir YouTube ein Video empfehlen, Users
12 Freqrounds, allein schon das, ob ich das gucken soll, ist schon mal sehr fraglich bei
dieser Kombination, aber dann von vor neun Jahren, ah, Kokona-Video, excellent, was bin
ich hier sehen, welcome to America, oh mein, das ist ein Reaction-Video, bedeutet das,
wenn wir das gucken, reacten wir auf Reaction-Videos, ne, das machen wir nicht, alter, die sehen
aber auch schon mal alle krass Kokona aus, oder, alter, die sind ja, die sind ja inbegriff
von Kokona hier, der nicht auf Twitch gesperrt, wer ist das überhaupt, was, alter, die Amis,
Alter, richtig Fallfat-Content wieder, oh man, naja, gut, nachdem YouTube es nicht schafft,
irgendwelche sinnvollen Videos zu empfehlen, weil YouTube meine Cookies vergessen hat,
das macht Kokona, okay, nichts, was ich gucken will, next, ich war letztens Pizza essen,
ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon erzähle, ich war letztens Pizza essen, da hab ich mich
hingesetzt, hat mich dann der, der, äh, was ist das, Kellner, ja, Kellner, null, ich war
die ganze Zeit Waiter, mir ist das deutsche Wort nicht eingefallen, äh, ist der Kellner
gekommen und hat gemeint, ah, haben sie, haben sie Impfen, haben sie einen Impf-Impf-Nachweis
dabei, hab ich gesagt, oh nee, hab ich jetzt nicht, aber ich hab, ich hab einen Impfausweis
im Auto liegen, und dann meint er zu mir, ach, sie haben einen Impfausweis im Auto, dann
ist okay, was darf's denn sein, hab ich mir auch gedacht, es ist genau das Eingetreten,
was ich gesagt hab, die, die ganzen Geschäfte haben überhaupt gar kein Interesse dran,
das irgendwie zu kontrollieren, New iPhone, New Anti-Repair Tactics, Anti-Repair Tactics,
okay, das, das gucken wir uns jetzt an, weil ich kauf, weil ich wollt mir ein neues iPhone
kaufen am Ende des Jahres, allerdings kein 13er, sondern auch ein 11er, und auch nicht
für mich, jetzt, jetzt wollt ihr es aber wissen, huge, der, der huge Jeffrey ist das, also was
mich am meisten geschockt hat, bei, ähm, was ich mal gesehen hab in einem Video, wenn
es darum ging, was Apple gegen Repair macht, wenn du ein original iPhone Display, oder
was, ein Display, ich glaub, es war ein Display, wenn du, wenn du das Display tauscht von einem
original iPhone zu einem anderen original iPhone, also wenn du quasi die Base von einem,
von einem iPhone nimmst und das Display von einem anderen iPhone und pappst das zusammen,
dann bootet es zwar, aber mit deaktivierten Funktionen, also die machen irgendeine Art
und Weise von, ähm, Handshake, was auch immer, zwischen Display und, und Mainboard, obwohl
es das original ist, geht da nicht alles.
Nein, die haben das auch schlimmer gemacht, du glaubst ja nicht ernsthaft, also ich glaube,
das letzte, wovor wir ausgehen, ist, dass Apple irgendwas daran geändert hat.
Auf geht's.
Ernsthaft?
Es ist keine, es ist kein Ladegerät und keine Kopfhörer mehr beim 12er dabei?
Wirklich nicht?
Ich hab, wie gesagt, ich hab er Anfang des Jahres in 11er ausgepackt und da war das noch
dabei.
Ich mein, der Scheiß kostet, wie viel, in ordentlicher Ausstattung 1200 Euro, da kann
man, für den Preis kann man nicht erwarten, dass da irgendwie ein Ladegerät oder Kopfhörer
dabei ist, ne?
Das ist Apple, ah Gott, das, na gut, da sparen sie halt 5 Euro.
Für die Umwelt, jaja, Apple, das habt ihr euch schön, also die Aussage von Apple ist
ja nur wirklich krass debatet, als wäre das für die Umwelt.
Das ist für Tim Cooks Konto ist das, wobei man ja sagen muss, das hab ich letztens irgendwo
gelesen, dass Tim Cook gar nicht so viel Jahresgehalt bekommt wie andere Top-Manager, aber der hat
jetzt irgendeine Aktienpaket-Auszahlung bekommen, weil er eine Weile dabei ist und das ist irgendwie
auch auf Einschlag irgendwie gerade 80 Millionen wert gewesen oder sowas, also am Hungertuch
nagt Tim Apple nun auch nicht, ja?
90% der Käufer haben ja auch schon eins, nein, das ist nicht sinnvoll.
Bei einem Gerät für 1200 Euro sollte man das so liefern, dass man es verwenden kann
ohne Zusatzgeräte zu kaufen, ohne Zusatzgeräte zu kaufen.
Ja, da hätt ich jetzt auch mit gerechnet, wenn man die auspackt, dass die beide fully
functional sind.
Genau, und weil ja auch gerade nicht reparierbare Geräte so umweltfreundlich sind, also wenn
Apple was von Umweltschutz erzählt, dann ist das, generell muss man sagen, es ist
aktuell im Trend umweltfreundlich zu tun, ohne umweltfreundlich zu sein.
Wartet mal kurz, ich hab übelst Frosch im Hals heute, okay, besser, ist oft Greenwashing,
ist fast alles Greenwashing.
Leute, ich bekomme neuerdings Twitter-Werbung von irgendeinem Ölkonzern oder sowas, die
sich auch erzählen, wir setzen uns für erneuerbare, nachhaltige Änderungen, bla bla bla bla.
Ihr habt einfach entdeckt, dass sich das aktuell gut verkaufen lässt, das sind genauso
wie wenn dann irgendwelche Bierhersteller um die Ecke kommen, so für jede verkaufte
Flasche pflanzen wir einen Baum und solche Geschichten, das ist einfach nur weil die
gemerkt haben, das kommt jetzt gut an, das ist nicht um wirklich was für die Umwelt
zu machen.
Das ist tatsächlich so, am meisten, ohne Scheiß, am meisten würde es bringen sich
nicht laufend Sinn, sinnlose Sachen zu kaufen und vor allem nicht so viel Plastik ins Meer
zu pumpen, bzw. wir pumpen das Plastik nirgends ins Meer, aber es gibt ja Satellitenbilder,
da siehst du aus dem Weltall Plastikteppiche auf dem Meer, die irgendwie so groß wie Deutschland
oder Hessen, glaube ich so groß wie Hessen sind, das ist schon heftig und die machen
das alle nicht für die Umwelt.
Aber was man daran sieht ist, das ist eigentlich ein ganz gutes Beispiel, die Hersteller machen
das nicht für die Umwelt, die Hersteller machen das, weil es sich gut verkaufen lässt,
für die eigene Tasche, aber daran, dass das möglich ist, dass man quasi sagen kann,
man ist umweltfreundlich und die Leute kaufen deswegen Sachen, dann sieht man, dass sich
es durchaus lohnen kann, auch wirtschaftlich umweltfreundlich zu sein.
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine, also wenn man das schafft, umweltfreundlich die Sachen zu produzieren,
das ist jetzt schon ein Merkmal, wenn das dann auch wirklich stimmt, was die Leute dazu
bringt, das zu kaufen, also so komplett unsinnig ist das Ganze gar nicht, das finde ich an
sich eigentlich ganz gut, dass man das daran sieht.
Na ja, gucken wir mal weiter, jetzt erst mal iPhone, iPhone Repair, Gift-Sub, Dankeschön,
Leona Bomber hat es abgegiftet an Carnetos, Carnetos, Glitch-Sub-Scription hier, Versiv.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr was, ich muss jetzt noch mal Pause machen, seit Apple damit angefangen
hat mit diesen Kameras, die so aus dem Gehäuse gucken, machen ja viele Hersteller nach, ich
glaube einige der aktuellen Samsung Top Smartphones haben ja auch so Dinger, so Kameras, die raus
gucken, es ist verständlich, es ist verständlich, warum das so ist, ich meine du kannst halt
Linsen und Kameras besser, umso kleiner, umso beschissener, also das verstehe ich schon,
dass man das so baut, was ich ja persönlich halt ein bisschen dumm finde, ist, dass man
das Handy nicht mehr flach auf den Tisch legen kann, ohne Hülle zu haben, ich habe hier
auch ein iPhone 11, da guckt es nicht ganz so krass raus, aber wenn ich das iPhone 11
ohne Hülle auf den Tisch lege, dann legt es nicht plan auf und das finde ich ehrlich
gesagt ziemlich kacke, gut, das geht schon ewig nicht mehr, das macht es aber nicht
besser, nur weil es ewig nicht geht, ah yes, dann machen wir es jetzt wieder, ich glaube
das habe ich noch gar nicht gesehen, das geht bei meinem 11 wahrscheinlich gar nicht, oder?
Limit Frame Rate, stimmt, die neuen haben jetzt ja auch 120hz oder sowas, stört das
wirklich wenn es sich flach auf dem Tisch legt, ja das stört, z.B. wenn es Vibrationsalarm
macht und dann so ganz komisch hin und her wackelt auf dem Tisch, ich mag das überhaupt
nicht, zumal ich das Handy auch ab und zu auf den Tisch, gerade beim Essen mache ich
das so, ich gucke dann rein, dass das Face ID unlockt, entsperrs und lasse es flach
auf dem Tisch liegen und tippe dann darauf rum, sei es jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen Musik
hin und her machen, ja ich benutze das total oft flach aufliegend, mir würde das mega
auf den Sack gehen, wenn das nicht flach aufliegt.
Das Apple Turn In Programm, das ist so halbe halbe, das mag zwar, das mag vielleicht gut
für die Umwelt sein, zumindest sieht es auf den ersten Blick so aus, ich glaube das Apple
Turn In Programm ist aber aus anderem Grund entstanden, müssen wir mal gucken ob es dazu
Analysen gibt, meine persönliche Vermutung ist, dass das Apple Turn In Programm halbwegs
attraktiv gehalten wird ist, dass es auf dem Gebrauchtmarkt nicht so viele Apple Geräte
gibt, weil Apple kein Bock hat, weil die Dinge auch lange supportet werden, weil Apple kein
Bock hat, dass ihre Geräte wirklich die komplette Lebensdauer im Umlauf sind, sondern Apple
will ja neue Geräte verkaufen und neue Geräte verkaufen ist dumm, wenn du für den Hälfte
der Preis ein 3 Generationen altes iPhone bekommst, das mag Apple nicht, also ich glaube
das ist aus mehreren Gründen entstanden, das mag zwar vielleicht auch dem Umweltschutz
zu Gute kommen, aber ich gehe wie bei vielem davon aus oder wie bei nahezu allem, was die
machen und nicht nur Apple, dass das vielleicht zum Teil was mit der Umwelt zu tun hat, aber
zum größten Teil es um den eigenen Geldbeutel geht, wo man auch wieder sieht, wenn man es
schafft Umwelt und eigener Geldbeutel zu verbinden, dann ist das für die gesamte Menschheit eigentlich
die beste Variante, weil dann haben die alle einen Anreiz was zu machen, boah, ich weiß
nicht, irgendwie tut mir das immer, ich denke immer es geht kaputt, wenn ich da irgendwie
einen mit so einem Saugnapf und so einem Spachtel das auf Dingsen sehe, aahhh, ich weiß nicht,
da muss man aber genau wissen, was man macht, Garantie, Cakewave, Bye Bye Garantie,
ja, warum ist da innen ein Apple Logo, das müssen wir Tim Apple fragen, ja, ja, ja,
wahrscheinlich um zu sagen, dass das Originalteile sind, wobei ganz ehrlich, als würde es in
irgendeine Art und Weise die China-Chinesen davon abhalten, eine Fake-Teil zu machen,
wo auch das Logo drauf ist, das juckt die doch absolut überhaupt nicht, also die Chinesen
kriegen da mittlerweile so gute Fakes hin, da also, ne, das ist denen auch egal, Sausmaster,
danke für 700 Subscriptionen, wenn da das Logo drauf ist, kann er Zoll kassieren, ne,
das juckt die Chinesen doch nicht, die Chinesen machen das, dass es so aussieht, als wären
es Originalteile, wobei man eine Sache mal den Chinesen zugute halten muss, ja, die
sind mittlerweile, also die Chinesen machen es genau richtig, die Chinesen, also man davon
abgesehen, dass es verboten ist, aber das ist in China eben ein anderes Problem, die Chinesen
machen es genau richtig, die Chinesen fahren auf der einen Seite die Schiene, wir können
die Sachen billig nachbauen, die die Leute haben wollen und auf der anderen Seite haben
die mittlerweile auch natürlich dann zu teureren Preisen, haben die mittlerweile auch ziemlich
gute Produkte, die die Leute kaufen wollen, obwohl sie wissen, es ist ein China-Produkt,
bestes Beispiel sind da die ganzen Xiaomi-Geschichten, das kaufen die Leute, sie wissen, dass es
ein China-Produkt ist und sie sagen, das ist für mich so attraktiv, dass ich das auch
zu einem bisschen teureren Preis kaufe, weil es konkurrenzfähig ist, wenn nicht sogar
besser und gerade preisleistungsmäßig besser als von vielen anderen Geräten, gerade die
Staubsauger-Roboter und sowas, also die Chinesen machen es eigentlich genau richtig, die haben
billigen Fake-Kram, den die Leute in Massen kaufen und die haben relativ gute eigene
gebaute Sachen mittlerweile, die die Leute auch kaufen, also die haben quasi nichts,
was es nicht gibt.
Hört ihr euch noch dran erinnern, wie ich die iFixit, das iFixit-Spachtel verbogen habe
im Stream?
Ich bin immer wieder überrascht, wie übertrieben einmotorisch oder so feinmechanisch diese
Dinger gemacht, das ist keine Schweizer Uhr, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine, wie kleinteilig
der Kram innen drin ist und das Dumme ist ja, wenn du bei einer Sache nicht aufpasst, geht
das Telefon nicht mehr.
Ist das WLAN?
Nee, Wattini-Anschluss.
Da sind überall QR-Codes drauf, warum sind denn da QR-Codes drauf?
Wahrscheinlich, dass die Genius Bar die Sachen besser tauschen kann, die nennen sich ja wirklich
so.
Also am Anfang immer, das ist ein Witz, also wenn du in so einen Apple-Shop gehst und dort
Support brauchst bzw. dein Gerät reparieren lassen willst, dann musst du ja zur Genius
Bar.
Und ich dachte früher immer, das ist ein Witz, weil ich so, ich dachte, also ursprünglich
dachte ich, das ist ein Witz, weil man damit sagen wollte, hey die Leute sind so unfähig
und da sind ja Genius so in Anführung geschrieben, aber nein, das heißt wirklich Genius Bar.
Ich würde mich das, das würde ich mich nie trauen, das würde ich mich nie trauen, ohne
Scheiß.
Da musst du schon genau wissen, was Sache ist, das würde ich mich nie trauen, das hier
mit einem Plastikstück rauszuhebeln.
Im Leben nicht, also ich würde mein iPhone auch gar nicht ausmachen.
Aufmachen, boah, das sieht wirklich aus, als kannst du da extrem leicht was kaputt machen.
Also ich würde da so viele critical Information lecken, um so ein Ding auszubauen, ich würde
es, ich würde es, ich, also ich würde es definitiv kaputt machen.
Warum sind das Gold-Konnektoren, Gold und Silber, ich glaube die Gold- und Silber-Konnektoren
sind einfach nur so, dass man es nicht so verwechselt, oder?
Das muss kein wirklich Gold-Konnektor sein.
Also ich würde es wahrscheinlich nicht mal auseinander bekommen, ohne es kaputt zu machen
und wenn ich es tatsächlich auseinander bekommen sollte, ohne es kaputt zu machen, würde ich
es wahrscheinlich nicht mehr zusammen bekommen, gehe ich mal von aus.
Traut sich das jemand von euch zu, traut sich das jemand von euch zu, so ein Ding auseinander
zu bauen und wieder zusammen zu bauen, also ich würde es mir nicht zutrauen.
Hast du es schon gemacht, okay.
Schon oft gemacht, chat, schibetet ihr oder habt ihr das wirklich schon oft gemacht?
Laptop würde ich auch auseinander nehmen, aber mein Smartphone nicht.
Ich sehe da chat, es ist eine richtig high IQ-Chat wieder angesagt hier.
Genau, das ging das letzte Mal nicht, du konntest das Display und das, ich sag mal Board, was
auch immer da alles drunter ist, konntest du auseinander machen, aber dann gingen manche
Funktionen nicht.
Jetzt ist das Board installiert, alles andere im Smartphone ist aus dem anderen Smartphone,
mal sehen wie es reagiert.
Nach dem Powering gibt es mehrere Messages aus dem Settings-App.
Verlangen das Smartphone eine wichtige Kamera- und Display-Message.
Begegnet, mehr zu tappen.
Er sagt, dass diese Teile unbegegnet werden können, als genügend Apple-Komponenten.
Wir sehen auch einen unbegegneten FaceID-Message zu aktivieren.
Tappen mehr auf diese Messages wird euch auf Apple's Website bringen, wo es euch
auf Apple und ihr Smartphone zur Verfügung stellt.
Das ist das, was wir mit dem iPhone 12 gesehen haben, aber der iPhone 13 nimmt es ein Stück
weiter, mit noch mehr Problemen, die vorbeikommen sind, die nicht besser geworden sind.
Für die, die unbegegnet sind, ist die Batterie-Heiligkeit zerstört worden, mit FaceID und True Tone.
Ein bisschen näher, habe ich eine Menge Funktionen auf dem Smartphone getestet.
Ich meine, technisch ist das wahrscheinlich komplett Nonsens, ja?
Also, das ist absichtlich eingebaut worden.
Also das ist Schwachsinn, dass das irgendwie einen technischen Grund hat, dass das so sein
muss.
Yep, kannst du vergessen.
Ja, es wird genauso wenig funktionieren.
Die Frage ist, ob das überhaupt funktioniert, keine Ahnung, wie das in Kanada läuft, aber
im Zweifelsfall würde das erstmal auf mehrere Jahre Rechtschreit rauslaufen, weil Apple wird
natürlich nicht sagen, dass sie das eingebaut haben, um Self-Repair zu verhindern, sondern
Apple würde sagen, das ist technische Notwendigkeit, wie sie das gebaut haben.
So, und dann müsste man das erstmal Apple beweisen, dass das Schwachsinn ist, das braucht
wahrscheinlich wieder zehn Jahre Rechtschreit.
Ja, war klar, schonmal was von TempleOS gehört, klar, der Typ, der ist übrigens mittlerweile
gestorben, der TempleOS-Programmierer, der hatte den, der TempleOS-Typ, der hatte den
übelsten Dachschaden, ja, der hat ja, also TempleOS ist ja nicht, also wer das nicht
kennt, da muss ich mal kurz was zu sagen, also das ist ja ein Typ, der hat ein Betriebssystem
programmiert, was quasi so hier Bibel-Themed ist und nicht einfach nur, weil er irgendwie
besonders gläubig ist und das geil findet oder so, der Typ ist besonders, besonders gläubig,
also der war der Meinung, Gott hat ihn beauftragt, ein Betriebssystem zu entwickeln und Praege,
genau, also oder Jesus, keine Ahnung, oder Gott, was weiß ich, hat ihn, Gott hat ihn
beauftragt, ein Betriebssystem zu entwickeln, aber das witzige ist, Gott hat ihm auch genaue
Vorgaben gemacht, was das Betriebssystem haben soll, also Gott hat zum Beispiel gesagt,
16 Bit Farbtiefe ist genug und sowas in der Richtung, 600, genau, Gott hat gesagt, 640
mal 480 Auflösung, ich weiß nicht, was ist denn da, also der Typ hat echt einen harten
Knall, also der Typ hat echt einen harten Knall, ja, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht steht
das, vielleicht steht das im Wikipedia Artikel sogar, hallo, vielleicht steht das auf Wikipedia,
gibt es einen deutschen Artikel, ne, okay, zeig mal her, hier, hier, guck, guck, also
der, das ist Terry Davis, der Stella Spokuehler, der sagt, Specifications, so, 640 mal 480
Resolution, 16 Color Displays, Single Audio Voice, we're instructed to him by God, also
der hat wirklich einen harten Knall gehabt, der Typ, ja, das ist zu geil, aber einen zieht
man daran mal wieder, das muss nicht zwangsläufig schlecht sein, also anscheinend hat es ja in
ihm schon zu gewissen Taten animiert und in dem Fall man könnte sagen, also quasi sinnvolle
Taten, ich weiß es nicht, ich weiß nicht, wie wirklich sinnvoll das ist, aber er hat
zumindest was daraus gemacht, aber ist schon der Wahnsinn, also wie wirklich pepeger Leute
im Kopf sein können, achso, das wurde auch übrigens in Holy Sea programmiert, normales
C ist zu unrein wahrscheinlich, also der Kerl hat wirklich einen Hardcore Knall gehabt,
also richtig, richtig mega heftigen Knall, so wo sind wir hier, was habt ihr stehen geblieben,
Apple, so weiter, trotzdem ist es setge, ja, ich glaube da war ja sogar Obdach los dann
später und so, richtig setge, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok.
In Fakt haben sich die Kameraschäden etwas verändert.
Jetzt ist die Kamera nicht mehr stabil.
Anstatt das Bild zu sehen und nicht zu sehen zu können,
ist der Finder nun gefräst und update sich nur ein paar Sekunden.
Das geht für die Cinematik und die Portofos des Phones.
Bei einer näheren Inspektion ist das Phone, das ich auf ein anderes Bild von iOS 15.0 eröffnet habe.
Es sieht aus, dass diese Phones auf einer vorverlaufenen Version geübt werden.
Ich werde das andere Phone updaten, um zu sehen, ob es die gleichen Ergebnisse bekommt.
Nach dem Updaten haben wir nun zwei Phones, die die Kameraschäden gefräst haben.
Irgendwie hat das Update mehr Probleme gemacht.
Wer hat sich diese Fake-Glitches ausgedacht?
Wir wissen, welche Probleme auftauchen. Es ist Zeit, um herauszufinden, was eigentlich passiert ist.
Jetzt gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder alle Fehler sind gefixt, oder Apple merkt sich, dass da mal ein falsches Display dran war und ist nach wie vor kaputt.
Aber ich glaube, das geht jetzt einfach wieder.
Ansonsten könnten die das ja auch gar nicht tauschen.
Funktioniert.
Absichtlich ist das eingebaut.
Nur die Kamera.
Das ist so krass kleinteilig. Ich hätte es schon zehnmal abgebrochen. Ohne Scheiß.
Guck mal, die haben irgendeine Authentifizierung, irgendeine Checksumme, irgendeinen Handshake.
Das musst du ja aktiv einbauen.
Das heißt, im Endeffekt bezahlt man bei einem iPhone mit, dass Apple diese Sachen eingebaut hat.
Weil das hat ja auch Entwicklungszeit und Aufwand gekostet. Also man bezahlt quasi mit seinem eigenen Geld mit, dass man es nicht reparieren kann, wenn man so will.
Aber gut, das muss man halt wissen. Das ist ja bekannt und im Prinzip bezahlt man das willentlich mit, wenn man Apple-Geräte kauft.
Ich bin ja da auch schuld, ich habe auch genug Apple-Geräte.
Vielleicht checkt das iPhone nur, wenn man die Kabel disconnectet. Dann dürfte es ja auch nicht auf magische Art und Weise wieder gehen, wenn man das Original anschaltet.
Das musst du schon erkennen.
Diebstahlschutz?
Na, ich weiß nicht.
Diebstahlschutz? Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wie weit das was zum Diebstahlschutz beiträgt.
Das ist eh verschlüsselt da drauf, dein Zeug. Und du kannst das ohne Passwort nicht entschlüsseln. Also vollkommen egal, ob da einer die Kamera austauscht oder nicht.
Um mit Fake-Hardware per Face-ID zu entsperren.
Da habe ich so meine Zweifel, ob das möglich ist oder nicht.
Sobald es eine Original-Kamera ist und es danach auch nicht funktioniert. Nee.
Selbst wenn Apple das sagt, klingt mir das doch hart vorgeschoben.
Würdest du ein 99 Euro Android-Phone mit einem 99 Euro iPhone gleichsetzen? Das kommt ja auf das Telefon an.
Ich habe ja selbst einige iPhones und einige Android-Geräte.
Was ich nicht habe, muss ich sagen, ich habe kein Desktop-Mac. Ich beziehe das jetzt nur mal auf Android und iOS, was Tablets und Smartphones angeht.
Ich hatte alles schon mehrfach. Ich glaube, ich habe mittlerweile mit dem neuen iPad 12 Tablets und ungefähr 3 Viertel davon ist Android-Kram.
Ein bisschen höherpreisiger ist zumindest eins dabei, was mir überhaupt nicht gefallen hat.
Also ich muss sagen, mal auf Tablets bezogen, muss ich sagen, das iPad ist einfach meilenweit vor allen Android-Tablets, die ich bisher hatte.
Sowohl von der Haptik her, als auch von der Bedienung her, als auch von der Geschwindigkeit her, als auch generell von allem.
Also Tablet-mäßig würde ich sagen, not even close.
Smartphone-technisch kommt es eigentlich letztendlich darauf an, was man haben will und was nicht.
Das kann man nicht sagen. Das hat alles seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Also ich würde keinem, der Android verwendet, einreden wollen. Er soll jetzt ein iPhone verwenden und ich würde keinem iPhone-Fan einreden, der das der Android verwenden soll.
Es sei denn, die Leute wollen irgendwas machen, was halt weder mit dem einen oder mit dem anderen nicht richtig geht.
Dann muss man natürlich sagen, Pech gehabt. Wenn ich zum Beispiel mein iPhone ordentlich automatisieren will, dann klappt das nicht.
Du kannst iPhones oder iPads nicht ordentlich automatisieren.
Sowas wie Tasker gibt es nicht für iPhone. Ist auch technisch nicht möglich, umzusetzen unter iPhone.
Das ist halt einfach Apple-Policy und deutlich restriktiver, was Background-Apps angeht, was automatische Eingaben angeht.
Also sowas wie Tasker und das ganze Plugin-Ökosystem ist einfach unter iOS-technisch nicht möglich. Das will Apple auch nicht.
Was die meisten Leute aber gar nicht brauchen. Für mich zum Beispiel als Dashboard an der Wand für Heimautomatisierung ist ein iPad deswegen nicht brauchbar.
Deswegen habe ich Android-Tablets hängen. Aber beim Smartphone kommt es echt drauf an, was man haben will.
Deswegen würde ich halt schon sagen, ja, wenn du ein Android-Benutzer bist und ein Android-Phone haben willst, dann ist ein 999 Euro Android-Phone bestimmt genau das Richtige.
Umgedreht würde ich sagen, ja, 1000 Euro iPhone wahrscheinlich genau das Richtige.
Also bei Smartphones ist wirklich die ganz entscheidende Frage, was man haben will.
Ich würde mir kein 999 Euro Android-Phone kaufen, weil ich die letzten Jahre zum größten Teil iPhones verwendet habe.
Und ich damit rein aus User-Sicht alles soweit machen kann, bis auf ein paar Sachen, die mir auf den Sack gehen muss ich sagen.
Aber das insgesamt positive Bild überwiegt da für mich. Deswegen würde ich mir auch weitere iPhones holen.
Wobei ich ja glücklicherweise gar kein iPhone holen muss, weil ich das iPhone von der Firma, wo ich arbeite, gestellt bekomme.
Aber das iPad und sowas, das habe ich mir im vollen Besitz meiner geistigen Kräfte gekauft.
Ich sage das einfach wie es ist. Die meisten davon, um es mal zu endwire flexen, die meisten davon liegen rum und sind aus oder sind auch keine wirklich teuren Tablets.
Also das meiste davon, das ist zum Beispiel, also die Tablets setzen sich zusammen aus einem alten Tegra Note 7. Das hängt zwar noch an der Wand, wird aber nicht mehr verwendet.
Fire HD 8 wird auch nicht mehr verwendet. Zwei Fire HD 10s für das Dashboard an der Wand.
Ein altes Lenovo Billig Tablet, was ich damals von G2A bekommen habe. Das war das einzige Lenovo Tablet, was es gegeben hat, glaube ich.
Damals ein relativ teures, glaube ich, um die 400 Euro Android Asus Tablet, was ich nie wieder kaufen würde. Das Tablet hat es von Anfang an gesagt und es hat nie, obwohl es neu war.
Ich habe das Asus Tablet damals für meine Mutter gekauft und das Tablet war von der Verarbeitung her kacke. Es hat viel zu kleine Rand gehabt, sodass du immer mit dem Daumen aufs Display gekommen bist.
Und Asus hat gesagt, nachdem ich das Tablet gekauft habe, dass sie das jetzt einstellen und nichts mehr daran machen. Es hat nie was bekommen. Übrigens, ich muss euch ein lustiges Video zeigen.
Wartet mal. Wartet mal. Ich habe mich so weggekackt, weil einer gesagt hat, das Tagesschau Jugendwort. Das ist zu geil.
Jetzt muss ich euch angucken.
Ich bin echt erstaunt, wie komplett, wie soll ich sagen, neutral und emotionslos man das sagen kann.
Ich weiß nicht, ich bin 37. Ich habe es jetzt garantiert nicht mehr mit You. Digga finde ich am besten. Digga ist echt am besten.
Digga. Digga. Das ist zu geil. Ich habe das Video bestimmt schon 20 Mal angeguckt. Das ist so doof. Wir gucken jetzt das iPhone Video endlich fertig.
Also das Sensor Kabel kommt ans originale und das Display kommt ans andere. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt. Jetzt ist es doppelt dran.
Siehst du, die machen wirklich irgendeinen Handshake zwischen den Komponenten. Du kannst es nur nicht mal richtig ausdrücken. Wie geht das? Ach nee, der wärmt das, um das zuzumachen.
Alter. Also hätte ich es bis jetzt noch nicht kaputt gemacht, jetzt wäre es hinüber.
Da darfst du auch kein Heißkleber drunter machen oder so. Da kriegst du es nicht mal zu. Heißkleber wird da ziemlich hart.
Die checken das. Die checken das.
Das wird nicht springen. Das wird nicht springen.
Du musst zu Apple und es austauschen lassen.
Was ist True Tone?
Ja gut, das wissen wir doch. Das wissen wir doch schon. Natürlich funktionieren die noch. Das haben wir doch jetzt schon 3 Mal gesehen. Klar funktioniert es noch. Er baut es jetzt zusammen, schaltet es ein. Bam, es funktioniert. Das ist jetzt schon klar.
Ja, okay. Das können wir jetzt skippen. Wir wissen, dass es funktioniert.
Ja, das haben wir jetzt verstanden. Das müssen wir uns nicht auf ein 5.000 mal anhören.
Rides in 5.000, best memory. Das best memory ist eindeutig das mit dem meisten RGB drauf. Also in dem Fall würde ich sagen das rechte. Das ist zufälligerweise auch das schnellste, aber es kommt ja nicht auf die Geschwindigkeit an, es kommt ja auf das RGB pro Zentimeter an. Also das rechte ist das beste memory.
So, also was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an?
Ja, ich weiß was wir uns angucken. Wollte ich mir nämlich heute morgen schon auf dem Handy angucken.
Was sagt die GameStar zu New World? Da bin ich mal gespannt was da rauskommt. Kann man GameStar testen halten was man will. Ich finde es aber immer ganz interessant was die dazu sagen und ich bin immer noch der Meinung, leider ist mittlerweile fast alles paid auf der GameStar Seite.
Dass das in dieser Richtung die beste Gaming Zeitschrift ist, die wir noch haben. Mal gucken was die dazu sagen. Mal gucken von wem das Video ist.
Es ist kaum zu glauben, aber New World ist endlich erschienen und seit dem Release am vergangenen Dienstag macht das Spiel vor allem eins, Schlagzeilen. Vor allem darüber wie schwer es aktuell ist überhaupt ins Spiel zu kommen. Ich habe ja nun echt schon den ein oder anderen MMO Lounge erlebt, aber so ein...
Ich weiß nicht wie er heißt. Ich weiß nicht wie er heißt der Sprecher. Ist das nicht der der aussieht als wäre er direkt aus Vikings?
Julius, ja kann sein. Ja die Leute, jetzt mal ernsthaft, die Leute könnten einfach, gerade wenn die jetzt anfangen, die könnten einfach auf den Server gehen, der nicht so populated ist und hätten auch keine Warteschlangen.
Aber was natürlich doof ist, wenn du auf den Server gehst, der leer ist, dort 20 Stunden spielst und dann wird der Server mit der Zeit voll und du kommst nicht rein. Das ist halt das Sack.
Aber ich sag's euch, ich hab's am Anfang des Streams schon mal gesagt, die Leute werden sich in 3-4 Monate die Zeiten der Warteschlangen, die haben keine Serverprobleme. Die Server sind einfach voll. Die sind bloß auf 2000 Spieler ausgelegt und ich glaube in dem Fall noch nicht mal, dass es ein Design, also dass es ein Skalierungsproblem der Hardware ist. Ich glaube das ist absichtlich.
Da steckt eine Designentscheidung hinter die Server nur auf 2000 Leute zu machen. Keine wirklich technische. Ja aber ich sag euch, die Leute werden sich in 3-4 Monaten zurückwünschen, die Zeiten von heute, weil dann alle Server, 60-70% der Leute abgehauen sind, die Server leer sind, eventuell gemercht werden. Mal gespannt.
Das Spiel hatte glaube ich 800.000 oder fast eine Million oder so. Ich weiß nicht, übelst viele Spieler oder 500.000, ich glaube eine halbe Million, ich glaube eine halbe Million war es. Eine halbe Million Spieler, die es versucht haben einzuloggen zum Start, das sieht man ja auch. Gucken wir mal, wir können einfach mal gucken hier. Steam Stats New World.
Gucken wir mal da. 757. Ah gut, jetzt kommt das Wochenende, das ist quasi das erste Wochenende seit Release. Fast eine Million. Fast eine Million Leute und lasst uns mal im Februar gucken. Wir gucken im Februar mal.
Und ich predicte mal, dass wenn es hochkommt, die Hälfte der Leute noch da sind.
Ich bin da wirklich gespannt darauf, die Entwicklung. Ich glaube nämlich, die meisten Leute, die damit jetzt anfangen, spätestens wenn die auf Max Level sind, stellen sie fest, oh ist nicht so meins.
Und dass die meisten der Leute, glaube ich, mit dem Core Gameplay, so diesem Faction-Based PVP, New World gar nichts anfangen können. Aber gucken wir mal.
So, was sagt die GameStar? Ja, Sensen Reminder.
Hat das Spiel eigentlich mittlerweile eine Story? In der Alpha hat es das nicht wirklich. Es gab ein Intro und das war's. Ich denke mal, jetzt in der Vollversion wird das schon ein bisschen mehr sein.
Wobei ich persönlich kein MMO spiele, um Stories zu spielen.
Wie kann man bei New World die Server merken, wenn auf jedem Server die Map, du musst dich für einen Stand entscheiden. Und dann die Spielerdaten von einem zum anderen kopieren. Was anderes sehe ich da nicht.
Wow. Rock. Rock Notebook. Alles klar.
Wenn ich sowas schon sehe im Chat. Die Übersetzung wieder. Wahrscheinlich ist die Übersetzung relativ gut. Ich persönlich würde ja am liebsten spielen mit einem englischsprachigen Klein auf einem deutschsprachigen Server. Das wäre so meine Lieblingsvariante.
Der Ahnenwächter-Regent ist am Start.
Ja, Wohllote. Ja, das war in der Alpha auch schon so.
Das sieht man übrigens auch schon. Ich meine jetzt übrigens nicht ihn hier im Video, sondern die Leute, die sich darüber beschwert haben, dass 90% der Leute absolute Kacknoobs sind, die MMOs spielen.
Wir hatten das gleiche. Ich habe auch mit zwei Leuten zusammen gespielt, als wir New World gestartet haben. Natürlich war es auch so, dass einer nicht. Es gibt glaube ich vier verschiedene Startgebiete und zwei hatten Glück, die waren im gleichen Startgebiet.
Du kannst auch so oft den Charakter neu erstellen, wie du willst und dann hast du den gleichen. Aber es ist total easy. Es ist wirklich total easy.
Die Weltkarte ist aufgedeckt standardmäßig und du musst nichts machen außer die ersten 15 Minuten Quests und dann kannst du zum anderen laufen. Das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Du musst die Quest machen, bis du in die Faction kommst. Das dauert vielleicht eine halbe Stunde, 45 Minuten, wenn du lahm bist.
Und danach kannst du einfach zu deinem Mitspieler laufen. Das dauert eine Viertelstunde. Also es ist wirklich easy, aber die Leute checken es einfach wieder nicht.
Nach dem Tutorial sehe ich bereits andere Spieler um ein Lagerfeuer herum springen und Dinge craften und weiß, jetzt beginnt das Abenteuer. Dieses allgegenwärtige Gefühl von Neuheit und Entdeckung rund um einen MMO Release habe ich wirklich lange nicht mehr so erlebt. Die Welt sprießt nur so vor Leben.
Die Hintergrundmusik aus New World?
Die Hintergrundmusik kommt mir übelst bekannt vor. Ist die aus New World?
Was ist die Hintergrundmusik? Das ist doch nicht aus New World. Die kommt mir übelst bekannt vor.
Haben sie das hier drin stehen? Nee.
Wird mich echt mal interessieren.
Was ein Bild.
Aber was macht New World denn jetzt so anders, so neu? Also zum einen wäre da das Kampfsystem, das sich viel direkter anfühlt als die meisten MMORPGs. Es gibt leichte und schwere Angriffe, Blocken und Ausweichräume, Distanzwaffen muss akkurat gezielt werden und das richtige Timing ist alles entscheidend.
Das Kampfsystem macht tatsächlich Spaß. Die Musik ist aus New World. Es gibt auch Stellen ähnliche im Soundtrack. Kann sein, kam mir übelst bekannt vor. Das Kampfsystem macht tatsächlich echt Spaß. Hat mir einfach auch Spaß gemacht.
Aber New World macht gar nichts neu. Was New World macht, ist New World macht sogar vieles älter als neuere MMORPGs. Zum Beispiel, dass es ein Spiel ist, was viel auf Spielerinteraktion setzt. Was du bei Elder Scrolls so gut wie gar nicht hast. Das ist eine, man steht da auf PvP. Elder Scrolls ist ja das Solo-Quest-MMORPG.
Cheers, 999, Dankeschön für den Sub. Und Spielerinteraktion ist tatsächlich was, was mir lange Zeit in neuen MMORPGs abgegangen ist. Also aus diesem Gesichtspunkt müsste New World eigentlich genau das sein für mich.
Sobald die Streamer wieder Fortnite spielen, ist hier alles wieder gut mit der Warteschlange. Der hat nicht unrecht, der Typ. Das habe ich auch in einem der letzten Videos gesagt. Viele der Leute, die jetzt auf New World springen, machen das, weil sie mit ihrem Lieblingsstreamer zusammen spielen wollen.
Deswegen geht niemals in die Streamer-Fraktion auf dem Server. Es sei denn ihr wollt permanent Gebiete verlieren. Quickmuffs. Bester Chat. Wird New World auf den PC kommen? Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es auf was anderem als auf dem PC verfügbar ist.
Loki Turner, Dankeschön für den Sub. 6 aktive Skills ausgerüstet haben, 3 pro Waffe. Das muss man hier vielleicht nochmal kurz betonen, was er hier sagt. Da habe ich auch so das meine Bedenken, dass es am Anfang Spaß macht, aber am Ende eigentlich richtig abkacken wird.
7 lange Hotbars. Wir können immer nur 6 aktive Skills ausgerüstet haben, 3 pro Waffe. Genau. Du hast im Endeffekt nur 3 Skills pro Waffe in New World, was auch wieder bedeutet, du hast nach den ersten paar Levels deine Skills am Start, die du verwendest.
Danach speckst du noch ein bisschen Damage und Passive Bleeding und Gedöns, aber du verwendest quasi von Level 10-15 ab bis Level 60 die exakt gleichen Skills.
Das hat sich in der Alpha nicht so schlimm angefühlt, weil das Kampfsystem sich irgendwie gut angefühlt hat, aber ich habe da meine Zweifel, dass das auf Dauer irgendwie so der Renner ist.
Ich glaube das wird einfach zu schnell langweilig. Wenn man es mal mit BDO vergleicht, was das Kampfsystem angeht, BDO ist natürlich viel mehr mit rumgeportet und Immunity-Stells und sowas bei irgendwelchen PvP-Kämpfen, aber BDO hat auch ein relativ aktives Kampfsystem und dort hast du aber auch gleich mal irgendwie 20 Skills pro Klasse.
Da habe ich echt meine Zweifel. Da hat er recht, das fand ich auch gut in der Alpha. Hast du Final Fantasy XIV gespielt? 500 Stunden oder so?
Als das erste Addon raus war, wir haben das erste Addon komplett durchgespielt bis Endgame damals. Alexander war damals Endgame und dann haben wir festgestellt, nachdem wir das gemacht haben, also wir haben ja nicht irgendwie Progress Hard Mode oder so gemacht, haben wir festgestellt, es gibt nichts mehr, das Game ist fertig.
Es gab nichts mehr in dem Spiel zu machen. Wir haben das durchgesuchtet ein paar Wochen und es gab nichts mehr, es war einfach durchgespielt. Zumal es ja auch in Final Fantasy Endgame technisch zumindest zum damaligen Zeitpunkt nichts gab, außer Daily Währung sammeln oder Weekly Währung sammeln.
Das hat ein PvP, ich glaube sogar ein PvP mit Elo-System mittlerweile, aber ganz ehrlich, das hat mich da nicht großartig angesprochen, zumal es Capture the Flag war.
Dafür ist es gedacht, du spielst es durch bis zur nächsten Expansion. Naja gut, das Problem ist da halt bei mir und dem Fabian, wenn wir MMOs spielen in der Richtung, wir grinden das dann halt durch für 2 Monate und dann sind wir fertig und müssen dann 10 Monate auf die nächste Expansion warten.
Ja vielleicht sollten wir das nochmal spielen, wir haben einen Character auf Endgame von Heavensward Level, das heißt das bringt dir gar nichts.
Das heißt wir müssen im Prinzip 2 Erweiterungen nochmal durch Level und Quest, das könnte man machen, müssen wir den Fabian mal fragen, ob der da Bock drauf hat.
Ist Final Fantasy eigentlich immer noch angesagt? Esmond Gold hatte es ja eine Weile gespielt, aber den habe ich letztens wieder vorspielen sehen.
Ja da hat er recht, das Kampfsystem fand ich wirklich nice in der Alpha.
Es wird so viel Spaß wie schon lange nicht mehr in einem MMORPG. Was ich auch lange nicht mehr in einem MMORPG erlebt habe ist ein derart generisches Questdesign.
Wir haben Final Fantasy 14 und The Elder Scrolls Online in Sachen Storytelling ein anderes Level erreicht. Guild Wars 2 punktet mit dynamischen Events, Rennen und Rätsel.
Guild Wars 2 Herzchenquest. Boah hat mich das gelangweilt. Man könnte jetzt sagen das ist ja das coole an Guild Wars 2 gewesen, aber ich sage euch, Guild Wars Open World Herzchenquest, die du alle ablaufen musstest über die gesamte Worldmap.
Es hat mich so heftig gelangweilt, es war der Wahnsinn. Ich habe mich da richtig durchgequält durch Guild Wars 2.
Star Wars The Old Republic liefert moralische Entscheidungen und selbst Dauerbrenner WoW setzt inzwischen auf mehr Abwechslung.
Ja Pios, spielt ihr das noch? Ich habe den letztens vorspielen sehen wieder.
Hier stellt New World einen Rückschritt auf ganzer Linie dar.
Ja das stimmt, da hat er recht. Aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Ich finde das überhaupt nicht schlimm.
Wenn ihr euren NPC schon so einen Satz sprechen lasst, hat da nichts geklingelt?
Aber ich finde das übrigens überhaupt nicht schlimm, wenn MMOs so generic quests haben.
Ich finde es sogar cool, dass es so im Nachhinein, das habe ich damals, als ich noch ganz viel Dark gegrindet habe,
also schon eine ganze Weile her, also früher als ich viel gespielt habe, nie so wirklich realisiert.
Eine Sache, die ich da richtig cool dran fand ist, dass das Spiel keine Main Quest hatte in der Form von
du bist der Held, der die Welt rettet.
In Dark warst du so ein ganz normaler 0815 Hans, der da rumgelaufen ist und Monster gebashed hat oder Sachen gecraftet hat
oder du warst niemand Besonderes und das finde ich in einem MMO ehrlich gesagt auch genau den richtigen Ansatz.
Ich verstehe es, dass es vielen Leuten nicht gefällt, viele Leute wollen irgendwie der große auserwählte Held sein,
irgendwie den dunklen Herrscher besiegen, irgendwie König von Gebiet XY werden oder sowas.
Das ist für ein Singleplayer Story, mag das alles ganz cool sein, aber ich finde in einem MMO passt das nicht.
Es ist ja schon immer in einem MMO ein bisschen merkwürdig, wenn du zu einem NPC gehst und der NPC dir dann sagt
Auserwählter, du bist wieder hier, hier bekommst du diese einzigartige Rüstung, da gehst du in die Stadt
und in der Stadt laufen 80% auf deinem Level mit der Rüstung rum und sowas, das ist ja immer schon ein bisschen komisch.
Deswegen finde ich es eigen, das ist mir nie so eigen aufgefallen als ich das damals gespielt habe
und das fand ich im ursprünglichen World of Warcraft, ich habe ja nicht viel World of Warcraft gespielt, am ursprünglichen World of Warcraft auch nicht schlecht.
Du warst zu einem 0815 Noob, der in der Welt unterwegs war, du warst niemand Besonderes
und mittlerweile haben MMOs auch so die Story, du bist der große Weltretter und musst irgendwie den dunklen Herrscher besiegen und sowas.
Das passt eigentlich zu MMOs gar nicht so richtig, weil kein MMO Final Fantasy ist übrigens das beste Beispiel dafür.
Kein MMO kann dir sinnvoll erklären, warum jeder Spieler der Einzelne auserwählte ist, der die Welt rettet.
Das wird einfach ignoriert in MMOs, das ist so, aber in Final Fantasy ist das das beste Beispiel.
Du wirst ja in der Final Fantasy 14 Story zumindest, soweit ich die gespielt habe, wie gesagt, ich habe die nur bis Ende der Heavens World gespielt.
Da geht ja die Story los, du bist nur 0815 Dude, arbeitest dich dann so ein bisschen mit Gildenquests hoch
und irgendwann stellen sie fest, du bist der Warrior of Light und rettest die Welt.
Wie Final Fantasy, er kann es bis heute nicht erklären, warum 5 Millionen Warriors of Light Auserwählte rumrennen
und miteinander Monster bashen, die eigentlich jeder der Einzelne, der Einzige Auserwählte ist, so nach dem Motto.
Das ergibt keinen Sinn, deswegen finde ich den Ansatz, wie die das hier machen,
so super generic Quests ohne großartige Story, finde ich eigentlich für den MMO genau den richtigen Ansatz.
Natürlich gefällt das vielen Spielern, das verstehe ich auch wieder.
Übrigens, kann man eigentlich immer noch nicht schwimmen in dem Spiel?
In der Alpha hat man so eine ganz komische Unterwasserlauf-Animation gehabt, sah ein bisschen aus wie aus Fluch aus der Karibik,
wo die mit dem Boot unter Wasser gelaufen sind.
Aber ich glaube man kann immer noch nicht schwimmen, oder?
Also das ist schon ein bisschen, wie sagt man, so ein bisschen Cringe Bruder heutzutage.
Dazu kommt, dass die Quests uns teilweise gnadenlos auf halbe Welt reisen schicken,
nur um an einem anderen Ort kurz mit jemandem zu sprechen oder etwas aufzuheben.
Das ist gerade unter dem Aspekt der nicht vorhandenen Mounds ziemlich anstrengend.
Ihr werdet New World sehr sehr viel Zeit damit verbringen, mit gedrückter Autorun-Taste auf euren Bildschirm zu starren.
Gut, dass es Autorun hat.
Auch inhaltlich kann die Hauptstory mich bisher noch überhaupt nicht überzeugen.
Wir sind nach unserem Schiffbruch auf dieser Insel gelandet und sollen nun einen Weg finden.
Also ich meine mal ernsthaft, mehr Generic Fantasy Kost kannst du gar nicht bieten als dieser Dude da.
Unauffälliger Typ mit Kaputze im Wirtshaus.
Also unkreativer geht es ja nun wirklich nicht.
Ich finde es auch immer so unauffällig.
Das fand ich übrigens auch bei Assassin's Creed schon immer lustig.
Guckt euch mal das 2er an.
Da läufst du durch, ne nicht Venedig.
Was war das in Assassin's Creed 2?
Florence, Florence war das.
Du läufst durch Florence, die Leute ganz normal am Start.
Und du läufst da als einziger Dude rum mit so einem Mantel mit so einer grasen Kaputze auf.
Du tust so übertrieben stealthy an jeder Ecke und niemand sieht dich.
Niemand sieht dich, niemand fällt dir auf.
Das ist alles vollkommen okay.
Du bist da der größte Stelze aller Zeiten aber niemand bemerkt dich in Assassin's Creed.
In Assassin's Creed 2, da hatten ja die NPCs irgendwie auch nur zwei Sprüche wenn was war.
Ich kann mich noch an einen Spruch dran erinnern.
Wenn du einfach nur mitten in der Stadt die Wand hoch gerannt bist.
Da haben die NPCs gesagt so sinngemäß sowas wie was ist jetzt los?
Er muss verrückt sein.
Das haben die NPCs alle zwei Sekunden gesagt.
Okay, next.
Schiffbruch auf dieser Insel gelandet und sollen nun einen Weg finden die mysteriöse Verderbnis zu bekämpfen die das Land bedroht.
Sehr standard also.
Tonal passt das aber auch leider überhaupt nicht in die sonstige sei frei entdecke und baue nach Lust und Laune Mentalität.
Wenn wir immer zwischendrin für einen Handlungsstrang doch wieder der eine Außerwählte sein sollen der es mit der Bedrohung aufnimmt.
Es passt auch überhaupt nicht in das, hat er schon recht, passt auch überhaupt nicht in das Game.
Das ist wieder so ein weiterer Punkt das man versucht hat alles in dieses Game irgendwie rein zu packen.
Angefangen hat man mit einem PvP fokussierten Game was ja im Kern immer noch ist.
Hat versucht da noch Quests rein zu packen, hat versucht eine Main Quest reinzubauen, hat alles irgendwie versucht reinzubauen.
Einermaßen habe ich die Story zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt aber natürlich noch nicht zu Ende gespielt.
Waage aber zu bezweifeln, dass mich da noch etwas krass überraschen wird.
Wenn doch Asche auf mein Haupt.
Leider bleiben sowohl die Spielwelt als auch die NPC Charaktere in ihr zu jeder Zeit völlig identitätslos.
Aber in New World sind es eben die Spieler selber die sich innerhalb der Welt zu echten Identitäten entwickeln sollen.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
So sollte es im Prinzip eigentlich auch sein.
Deswegen sage ich vom Ansatz her so dass man mehr Spieler interaktion und...
Find ich das eigentlich eine gute Sache.
Nur dass ich finde das New World einfach so unzusammenhängend wirkt.
Ich kann das schlecht, kann das echt schlecht beschreiben.
...sprechen möchte, denen werden die langweilige Hauptstory und das banale Questdesign nicht allzu viel ausmachen.
Die setzen ihre eigenen Ziele und begeben sich in den befriedigenden Grind der sich füllenden Balken.
Und oh mein Gott hat New World viele Balken.
Das stimmt, 50 Milliarden Balken.
Jährlich nach dem Spielfortschritt ist den Entwicklern wirklich gut gelungen.
Egal was wir in der Spielwelt tun, alles bringt Erfahrung und verbessert unseren Charakter in irgendeinem Bereich.
Das ist auch sowas?
Das ist mir in der Alpha auch aufgefallen.
Du hast ja wirklich 30 Milliarden Balken.
Du hast XP, du hast Waffen, du hast Craft, du hast alles.
Also das ist jetzt die erste Waffe.
Du hast wirklich überall irgendwelche Balken.
Die Sache ist bloß die.
Wenn du mal 60 bist und es da nicht irgendwas gibt, dann ist mit den Balken und der Motivation daraus vorbei.
Vielleicht noch ein bisschen Crafting oder sowas.
Und genauso, es kann sein, dass ich komplett falsch liege.
Aber wir gucken uns das mal an.
Wie gesagt, wir gucken uns das in 3, 4, wir gucken uns das im Februar an.
Wir gucken uns das im Februar an.
Ich sage euch, die Hälfte der Leute, wenn nicht 70% der Leute, sind weg.
... Schwelle zum nächsten bedeutungsvollen Upgrade zu stehen.
Und so lässt sich der Grind in Kombination mit dem bereits erwähnten spaßigen Kampfsystem zumindest bisher mehr als gut ertragen.
Die entscheidende Frage ist, wie lange?
Denn im Gegensatz zu anderen MMORPGs bietet New World aktuell noch recht wenig Endgame spezifische Inhalte.
In WoW fange ich jetzt erst richtig damit an, meine Ausrüstung zu optimieren und mich Boss für Boss...
Und das ist an der Stelle eigentlich der Unterschied.
WoW ist, wie die meisten, sagen wir mal so viele MMOs, die danach gekommen sind, quasi ein Endgame...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es da einen Wort für gibt.
Item... Item... Ja... Item Level Upgrade Spirale, was komplett useless wird beim nächsten Addon.
Also durchgestyltes Endgame, Kreisel, Grind, Raid, Upgrade, Upgrade, Upgrade, nächstes Addon, useless.
So, wieder von vorne.
Das ist das, wie WoW seit einer Weile funktioniert und wie viele MMOs, die danach gekommen sind, funktioniert hat.
Das ist ja da, wo sich das mit New World unterscheidet.
Und eigentlich ein Punkt, den ich im Prinzip ganz gut finde, New World hat als Endgame ja hauptsächlich...
Zumindest so, wie sich das für mich jetzt darstellt, hauptsächlich PvP.
Und da ist halt die Frage, ob dieses PvP-System, so wie es jetzt ist, quasi überhaupt Endgame-tauglich ist.
Also sprich, dass das was ist, was du am Tag auch mal wirklich 5, 6...
Jeder so ein Hardcore-Kreisel-Grinder wie ich früher, aber die Leute müssen auch irgendwie zufriedengestellt werden.
Also ist das was, was man 5, 6 Stunden am Tag machen kann?
Oder sogar mehr, ja?
Alles in Kombination. Kann man... Will man das überhaupt machen?
Das ist ja die eigentliche Frage.
Vor allem, wenn man nur 3 Skills hat.
Also ich konnte da damals, als ich in Dark noch meine feste...
Oder mehr oder weniger feste Gruppe hatte mit Leuten, wo ich gespielt habe...
Da konnten wir das ohne Probleme 6, 7 Stunden am Tag machen, wenn nicht länger.
Da bist du durchs Grenzgebiet gelaufen, hast alles weggebasht, was nicht bei 3 auf den Bäumen war.
Nebenbei noch ein paar Festungen erobert, verteidigt gemacht.
Dann eventuell war noch irgendein Raid, wo man für ein paar Respec-Steine mitgemacht hat und so was.
Du konntest da ohne Probleme 24, 7, 365 Tage im Jahr durchspielen, wenn du wolltest.
Und du hattest aber auch Vorteile dabei.
Du konntest nämlich... Also in Dark war es so...
Ich nehme das jetzt nur als Beispiel, weil das ein MMO ist, was ich lange gespielt habe.
Und weil es halt bis heute das beste PvP MMO ist.
Und New World geht ja auch in die PvP-Richtung.
In Dark hast du bis 50 gelevelt.
Und dann, wenn du PvP gemacht hast, sei es jetzt, dass du Spieler gekillt hast oder Burgen erobert hast oder Relikte gesammelt hast, was auch immer.
Dann hast du zusätzliche Punkte bekommen dadurch und dann konntest du quasi PvP-Fähigkeiten skillen.
Und du konntest dich mega OP specken.
Du konntest beispielsweise als Heiler, konntest du dir quasi 3-mal komplett Mana wieder auffüllen und so was in der Richtung.
Was du mit Frischlevel 50 nicht konntest.
Was natürlich auch wahnsinnig motiviert hat, weiter PvP zu machen.
Weil du die Fähigkeiten sowohl PvM als auch PvP einsetzen konntest.
Und mal ganz ehrlich, so ein Realm Rank 10-Character versus ein 50er mit 1 war halt not even close.
Du hast den halt mal kurz weggereckt, so mit 3 Schlägen.
3 Krits, bam, weg.
...Rates zu kämpfen.
Ich habe also nach wie vor ein großes Ziel vor Augen.
Und alles, was ich tue, zielt darauf ab, mein Equipment zu verbessern, um dieses Ziel besser erreichen zu können.
So etwas fehlt in New World.
Hier werdet ihr neben ein paar besonders schweren Aktivitäten nach bekannten Mustern nicht groß etwas Neues zu tun bekommen.
Das kann gut oder schlecht sein, denn im Gegenteil...
Eveline Hexberg, das ist...
Ich weiß nicht, der Name klingt irgendwie sehr casual-mäßig.
Man darf das anhand der Spielernamen vielleicht nicht festhalten.
Aber es gibt so... Es gibt Character-Names, die schreien einfach so...
Irgendwie, hallo, ich bin ein ultra casual-Spieler.
Was nicht schlimm ist, vollkommen okay.
Jedes MMO, der Großteil der Spieler sind einfach Leute, die das Spiel casual nehmen, beispielsweise.
Das ist gar kein Ding, ja.
Aber ich finde, anhand der Namen erkennt man es teilweise schon irgendwie.
Also, wenn eine XXX der Pwner heißt, dann weißt du gleich, was Sache ist.
...der der Weg das Ziel ist.
Es gibt eigentlich keinen wirklichen Grund, bis zum Maximal-Level zu hetzen,
denn die meisten persönlichen Ziele kann ich einfach auf dem Weg dahin schon genauso gut angehen.
Ich habe beispielsweise keinen Vorteil daraus, meine Crafting-Spieler erst mit Stufe 60 zu leveln.
Im Gegenteil, ich bin eher gut beraten, das die ganze Zeit nebenher schon zu tun,
denn sonst wird mir im Endgame vielleicht etwas fehlen.
Dasselbe gilt übrigens auch für...
Ist übrigens auch ein Punkt, warum ich jetzt gesagt habe, ich will kein New World...
Ich habe ja die Alpha gespielt, zwar nicht ultra viel, aber es geht so.
Das ist eines der Punkte, warum ich jetzt...
Ich meine, ich habe mir den Kram sogar auf Steam, ja.
Warum ich letztendlich gesagt habe, New World ist wahrscheinlich doch nicht mein Game.
Eines der großen Säulen in diesem Game ist ja das Craften.
Und ich bin einfach jemand, ich mag Craften nicht.
Ich crafte in keinem MMO.
Ich habe in keinem MMO groß gecraftet und ich mag Craften nicht in MMOs.
Ich finde es gut, wenn es Crafting-Systeme gibt, dass Leute dieses gerne machen,
dass das machen können, dass es vollkommen geht.
Ich crafte einfach nicht gerne. Crafting ist echt nicht meins in MMOs.
Ich habe in keinem MMO groß gecraftet.
Auch das ist nicht in irgendeiner Form durch unser Level beschränkt.
Wir können uns nach der Fraktionswahl nach etwa ein bis zwei Spielstunden
direkt für unsere Fraktion ins Getümmel stürzen.
Fans von Open World PvP kommen hier voll auf ihre Kosten.
Überall in der Spielwelt brechen größere Schlachten zwischen den Fraktionen aus...
Das ist, das soll, was man hier sieht, das müsste eigentlich der eigentliche Kern von New World sein.
Das da.
New World macht deine Grafikkarte nicht kaputt,
es sei denn du hast eine minderwertig hergestellte Grafikkarte.
Das ist Blödsinn.
New World macht deine Grafikkarte auch nicht mehr kaputt als andere Spieler.
Der einzige Grund, warum New World so Probleme macht bei Grafikkarten ist,
weil die Leute so lange in der Warteschlange sitzen und das Hauptmenü nicht FPS-limitiert ist
und deswegen manche Grafikkarten überhitzen.
Wenn du nur ordentlich gebaute Grafikkarte hast, passiert dir dabei gar nichts.
Und du kannst es bestimmt auch anderweitig limitieren.
Wurde aber gefixt, da streiten sich die Leute, streiten sich die Geister drüber,
aber wie gesagt, einem Grafikkartenhersteller liegt es auf jeden Fall nicht.
So, hierzu ist gesagt, das habe ich in der Alpha mir auch angeguckt,
da gab es ja nie der Ecke Open World PvP, weil die Leute sich einfach bashen wollten.
Das hier müsste eigentlich der Haupt, und so war es glaube ich ursprünglich auch mal gedacht,
bevor man quasi New World von der ursprünglichen Idee umgebaut hat zu dem, was es jetzt ist.
Also das müsste der eigentliche Hauptgrund sein, New World zu spielen.
Dauerhafte PvP-Action, Faction gegen Faction.
Das Problem ist jetzt nur, was man eingebaut hat in New World,
dass, oder ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich ein Problem ist,
aber ich finde halt, daran sieht man, dass das Spiel nicht so genau sich festlegen will,
was es jetzt eigentlich machen will.
Du kannst dieses PvP hier einfach ausschalten.
Das ist halt fragwürdig, finde ich.
Also wenn du sagst, der Fokus dieses Games soll eigentlich,
also die Motivation dieses Games erwächst quasi aus,
Open World PvP, Belagerungen und Gilden stellst,
dass du dann PvP einfach ausschalten kannst, ist fragwürdig.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob es eine gute...
Ja, egal, wir machen jetzt weiter.
...Spieler, die sich für die Schlacht angemeldet haben,
eine Truppe von 50 mutigen Recken zusammenstellen,
mit denen es in eine große 50-gegen-50-Belagerungsschlacht geht.
Auch die gab es schon auf meinem Server.
Leider wurde mein kleiner Charakter aber bisher noch nicht ausgewählt.
Dies ist Batman.
Aber das ist es, was ich meine, wenn ich sage,
in New World machen die Spieler die Identität aus.
Dadurch, dass die Städte von aus Spielern geformten Kompanien geführt werden...
Was ich vom Ansatz her super finde.
...Projekte für die Entwicklung des Ortes in Auftrag geben,
sind die größten Kompanien schnell auf dem ganzen Server bekannt.
Und ihre Anführer werden leicht zu wichtigen Persönlichkeiten.
Das ist genau das Richtige für so 0815 No-Life-Leute.
So wie ich früher auch oder Fabian MMOs gespielt haben.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, wir haben beide...
Ich meine, ich kenne Fabian ja ursprünglich sogar aus dem MMO.
Wir haben beide gerne Leute gebashed.
Aber gilden Anführer und irgendwie Städteplanung machen,
hätten wir beide keinen Bock drauf.
Wir wollen keine Städteplanung machen oder sonst was.
Wir wollen rausgehen und Leute bashen.
Am besten noch mit ein paar anderen Leuten,
die auch gut im Leute bashen sind.
Aber du hast garantiert genug Leute, die dann übelst...
Ich kann es mir schon so richtig vorstellen.
Es gibt ein New World Roleplay Discords oder sowas,
wo... Ich kann es mir wirklich schon bildlich vorstellen.
Ich meine, GTA RP ist auch so ein Ding, wo man sieht,
dass manche Leute sich da richtig krass reinsteigern können.
Aber ich kann es mir auch so richtig vorstellen,
dass dann der aktuelle Stadtbesitzer
in irgendein New World Roleplay Discord geht
und dann wird dann erstmal der Fürst geroleplayt oder sowas.
Es gibt so Leute, die stehlen auch sowas.
Und gerade, dass es gut ankommt, sieht man ja auch bei GTA RP.
Ich nehme mich nicht aktiv daran teil,
aber ich gucke ab und zu mal ein paar Clips daraus.
Das kommt ja kaum vorbei.
Und du hörst das manchen Leuten an.
Die steigern sich da so krass drin rein.
Also sie roleplayen nicht mehr. Die sind das schon.
Die roleplayen dann wirklich Polizist und denken irgendwie hier...
Das ist teilweise richtig heftig.
Und ein wenig Glück herankommen.
Nicht nur der PvP Aspekt lässt sich wahlweise ignorieren.
Allgemein lässt sich New World auch sehr gut als Solospieler erkunden.
Und dadurch, dass es keine festen Klassen gibt,
könnt ihr sehr einsteigerfreundlich erst einmal wild alle Waffentypen
durcheinander probieren und kombinieren,
bis ihr etwas gefunden habt, das sich für euch gut anfühlt.
Einzig in den Expeditionen nimmt New World alte MMORPG-Traditionen auf
und erfordert ganz klar die Holy Trinity.
Unsere waghalsige Draufgängertruppe wurde hier jedenfalls gnadenlos aufgerieben,
sodass wir uns dann doch um eine richtige Kombination aus Tank heilen.
By the way, wer sich fragt, das grüne drum herum ist so ein Area Heal.
Das kann man nur wenn man diesen Heal Staff gespeckt hat.
Und Schadens aus Thailand bemühen mussten.
Mir ist natürlich durchaus bewusst...
Boah, das hab ich ja noch nie gesehen. Was ist denn hier los?
Looking for Heal ist normal. Looking for DD?
Moment, jedes Game hat nur DDs, Tank und Healer gibt's nicht.
Looking for DD? Was ist denn da los?
Sus, wie man so schön sagt heute, da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Vor DDs lookt nie jemand.
Es lookt eigentlich jeder nur für Healer und Tanks.
Mir ist natürlich durchaus bewusst, dass ich noch lange nicht alles gesehen habe.
Ein abschließendes Urteil zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt zu fällen wäre völlig unmöglich.
Aber nach vier Tagen mit New World kann ich zumindest einen Ersteindruck geben und dabei gleich entwarnen.
Nein, New World ist kein gescheitertes Spiel wie die vorherigen Versuche der Amazon Game Studios.
Noch nicht. Noch nicht.
Mal gucken, so ein MMO entscheidet sich ja nicht unbedingt jetzt zwei Wochen nach Release.
Der wahnsinnige Spieler-Antrag in den ersten Tagen zeigt, dass es diesen frischen Wind dringend gebraucht hat.
Das stimmt, da hat er recht, aber der Spieler-Antrag kommt auch durch den Streamer-Antrag.
Die meisten, die bisher spielen konnten, zeigen sich auch größtenteils von dem Spiel begeistert.
Aber New World ist nicht für jeden etwas. Es deckt kein so breit gefleckertes Interessengebiet ab.
Das werden eigentlich viele noch merken, die jetzt gerade da eingestiegen sind.
Dort kann ich Hardcore raiden, PvP spielen, beim Questen eine stringentere Hauptstory erleben, Mounds und Haustiere sammeln und und und.
New World richtet sich mit seinem Mix aus Survival, Crafting und klassischen MMO-Mechaniken hingegen vor allem an einen Spielertypen.
Wer Spaß daran hat, sich in einer ordentlichen...
Wer hat denn... Alter, was ist das denn?
Zack, die rustikale Küste im Dörfchen Erstes Licht findet diesen trendigen und unwiderstehlichen Urlaubsort.
What?
... einen Spielertypen.
Wer Spaß daran hat, sich in einer offenen Sandbox-Welt seine eigenen Ziele zu setzen und diese zu verfolgen
und einen so wenig wie möglich vordefinierten Charakter zu optimieren,
auch wenn das Optimieren oft um des Optimierens-Willen passiert und nicht in Hinblick auf ein großes Endziel wie etwa einen Raid-Boss,
für den könnte New World genau das sein, was er gesucht hat.
Wer in einem MMO aber eine spannende Story mit erinnerungswürdigen Charakteren...
Ja, das kannst du vergessen.
... und Motivation eher aus abwechslungsreichen Aufgaben statt aus sich füllenden Fortschrittsbalken gewinnt,
dem könnte in New World meiner aktuellen Einschätzung nach ganz schön schnell langweilig werden.
Ich ergehe mich auch von aus.
... jetzt vor allem darauf konzentriert die einzelnen Aspekte des Spiels zu bewerten.
Wenn ihr einen Überblick darüber haben wollt, wie zum Beispiel das Skill- und Attributssystem genau funktionieren,
dann schaut doch gerne mein Vorschau-Video an, das ich vor einigen Wochen gemacht habe, da erkläre ich das nochmal im Detail.
Und wenn ihr zufällig auf dem Server Ravenel in der Fraktion der Marodeure seid,
dann lasst euch doch von meiner Kompanie, der Brot-Legion, rekrutieren.
Oh, Piz-Chape.
Vielleicht schaffen wir das ja zusammen doch mal die Regentschaft einer Stadt an uns zu reißen.
So, ich bin jetzt fast am Ende der Warteschlange, ich muss also gleich weiterspielen.
Die Marodeure-Brot-Legion.
Danke euch fürs Zuschauen, euer Jules.
... so, ich wollte jetzt hier noch irgendwo was zu sagen, Zack.
Alter, ist ja gut.
Chet, sei aber aktiv heute.
So, ähm...
Moment.
Hier, da wollte ich was sagen.
Als halbwegs auch so ein Big New World, eher wie eine Evolution, nichts grundlegendes Neues.
Ich würde sogar sagen, es ist eine Defluktion.
Gibt es so was?
Ja.
Was ist das Gegenteil von Evolution?
Defluktion?
Rücksch...
Keine Ahnung.
Also vieles, was New World heutzutage macht, ist eigentlich überhaupt nicht mal angesagt
in MMOs.
Also, nicht...
Nee, das stimmt nicht.
Angesagt...
Deforged.
Genau.
Sondern die machen vieles wie MMOs, quasi...
Also, das stimmt nicht.
Angesagt...
Deforged.
Genau.
Ähm...
Sondern die machen vieles wie MMOs, quasi...
Früher das gemacht haben, so.
Ähm...
Relativ persistenter Server mit einer relativ kleinen Spielerbase, nicht zusammengemercht,
serverbekannt, kein Dungeon Finder, kein anonymes Go, Go, Go, Buff, Let's Go.
An sich eigentlich ein MMO, was mir gefallen müsste, leider...
Aber auch genug Punkte hat, wo ich nicht dran glaube, ja.
Kannst du dir das hier mal angucken?
Oh, das klingt Painschampic.
Oh nee, oh nee.
Wann ist es Computerspielsucht?
Oh nee.
Na, oh je.
Ich kenn das nicht, aber...
Allein schon der Titel und dass es vom NDR ist.
Oh nee.
Das ist...
Das tut schon weh beim Titellesen.
Gaming?
Okay, was sagen Gaming, soziale Medien, Internet nach einer Studie, bla, bla, bla.
Nutzen 700.000 Kinder und Jugendlichen Deutschland Computerspiele riskant.
Und pathologisch...
Was bedeutet pathologisch in dem Zusammen...
Ich...
In dem Zusammenhang?
Die Pathologie betrifft...
Ach nee.
Krankhaft.
Daddeln bis der Arzt kommt.
Alter.
Welcher Bube hat diesen Satz wieder geschrieben?
Daddeln bis der Arzt kommt.
Okay, wir gucken uns mal den Anfang an.
Das ist bestimmt hoch...
Ein ganz, ganz schlimmes Pantschamp-Video.
Ups.
Moment, wo sind wir?
Die Dislikes.
Ah, das heißt ja auf YouTube mittlerweile nichts mehr.
Ist das so ein PS3-Controller?
Nee, das ist ein PS4-Controller.
Das hat diesen komischen...
Dieses komische Touchpad.
Das hat das Touchpad.
Das ist noch...
Das ist ein PS4-Controller.
PS5-Controller, hat das eigentlich auch noch dieses komische Touchpad?
Oder ist das jetzt weg?
Ah, das sieht jetzt aber anders aus.
Okay.
Pamm.
Haha, genau.
So sitzt man immer vom Rechner.
Pamm.
So spiele ich auch immer mit dem Controller.
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt.
Der echte Gangster war einfach seinerzeit voraus.
Ich hab ihn 82 mal getötet und er mich 18 mal.
Durchschnittlich verbringen...
Das ist Black Ops 1?
Moment, nee, das ist Black Ops Dings Firing Range Remake, oder?
Nee, nee, nee, doch nicht.
Doch nicht, doch nicht.
Das ist 4.
Das ist Firing Range Remake.
Jaja, ist okay.
Moment mal, das Intro muss ich jetzt nochmal gucken.
Und Pamm.
Ich hab ihn 82 mal getötet und er mich 18 mal.
Durchschnittlich verbringen Jugend...
Moment.
82 in einem TDM?
TDM?
Sus.
Da hab ich meine Zweifel.
Private Match.
... fünf bis sechs Stunden täglich am Bildschirm.
In der Pandemie ist es deutlich mehr geworden.
Das sind Internetfreunde.
Wir haben uns in der Corona-Zeit kennengelernt.
Internetfreunde.
Sie werden immer jünger.
By the way, soll ich euch mal sagen, Internetfreunde,
wenn man sich mit Leuten gut versteht, das können durchaus...
Man kann es einfach Freunde nennen.
Wo ist das Problem?
Also, wenn man sich mit Leuten im Internet gut versteht...
Ich wüsste nicht, warum man das großartig unterscheiden müsste.
Egal, egal.
Es ist painstampig.
Digitale Medien schon im Kindergarten.
Ja.
Wir schaden den Kindern.
Oh nein!
Der Spitzer!
Der hat mir jetzt gefehlt.
Alter, was kommt denn als nächstes, die Pfeife oder was?
Das ist nicht meine Meinung.
Das ist medizinisch...
Oh, Spitzer.
Wie sollen sich Eltern verhalten?
Spitzer, nicht Schwitzer.
Wir können schlecht in der Erwachsenenwelt immer sagen,
Digitalisierung ist das Heilmittel für alle möglichen Probleme,
die Gesellschaft hat und dann gleichzeitig so eine romantisierende
Vorstellung von Kindheit haben, die möglichst nur im grünen Wald stattfinden soll.
Für manche wird das Zocken zur Sucht.
Sie landen in der Kinder- und Jugendpsychiatrie.
Der Typ, der ist eigentlich, wenn man solche Reportagen sich anguckt,
da macht er auch Vorträge und so zu diesem Thema,
der ist relativ bekannt und der ist halt komplett gegen Medienbenutzung bei Kindern.
Der hat schon durchaus sinnvolle Punkte,
wobei der mir deutlich zu aggressive ist mit seinen Ansichten.
Aber ganz extrem.
Man isst nicht mehr so viel wie vorher, trinkt jetzt zum Beispiel zum Wachboden.
Also in der Zeit, wo ich viel gespielt habe, habe ich eigentlich mehr gefressen,
vor allem mehr vor dem Computer als vorher.
Bleiben nur Energies, verliert die Interessen,
man macht nichts mehr mit Freunden,
man will eigentlich nur noch wirklich an seine Konsole und zocken.
Computerspiele und soziale Medien.
Ja heute spielt man halt mit seinen Freunden zusammen.
Das mit Zuchtfaktoren spielt.
Die Spieleindustrie hat somit eine hohe Verantwortung
und entzieht sich leider bisher jeglichen...
Spieleindustrie will Geld verdienen.
Ich bin ja auch kein Fan von vielen Glücksspielmechanismen in Spielen.
Aber jetzt nicht weniger aus diesem Hilfe unserer Kinder,
sondern eher, weil es die Spiele schlechter macht
und mehr Fokus darauf gesetzt wird, zu gucken,
wie kann man den Leuten möglichst easy ohne Gegenleistung Geld aus der Tasche ziehen
und am besten sie 3-, 4-, 5-mal für das gleiche Spiel bezahlen lassen.
Also mein Problem mit diesen Sachen ist eigentlich,
dass es die Spiele unterm Strich schlechter macht.
Natürlich ist es für einige, da haben die nicht unrecht,
ist es natürlich auch problematisch.
Digitale Medien in Kinderhand.
Ein Reizthema zwischen Eltern und Kindern.
Ich kenne keine Familie, wo es nicht so ist.
Überall ein ständiges Verhandeln.
Regeln werden aufgestellt, gebrochen, Streit Tag für Tag.
Ich bin noch mit nur 3 Programmen aufgewachsen.
Bei uns wurde Fernsehen stark limitiert.
Gezockt habe ich nie. Aber meine Kinder fahren total darauf ab.
Na, dann ist sie ja eindeutig die Beste, um diese Reportage zu machen.
Ich bin unsicher.
Am liebsten würde ich ihnen dieses Daddeln ganz verbieten.
Denn auch wenn die vereinbarte Zeit vorbei ist,
gibt es sowieso immer noch Diskussionen.
Andererseits gehört das heute wohl dazu.
Zocken tun alle, aber filmen lassen will sich kaum einer dabei.
Moment, ich würde mich auch nicht filmen lassen,
wenn ich gerade auf dem Klo kacken bin
oder einfach nur durch einen Garten laufe.
Ich will überhaupt nicht gefilmt werden.
Diese 3 Jungs, alle 15, stehen dazu.
Wollen aber auch, dass ihre Namen nicht genannt werden.
Also wir machen ja selber Kampfsport.
Und das ist auch so ein Campspiel.
Deswegen, es macht halt Spaß.
Oi!
Was haben sich denn da für 3-Hat-Leute rausgesucht, Alter?
Na gut, 15.
Da kann man nichts, da kann man das nicht erwarten.
Und nach der Schule oder so, wenn man kommt,
ist halt langweilig, wenn man im Fernsehen guckt
oder am Handy spielt.
Können wir auch individuell reden und spielen noch, wissen Sie?
Ja, genau. Wir spielen so Spiele, die man zusammenspielen kann.
Wir spielen zu dritt in einem 2-Spieler-Game.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist doch...
Wie wollen die das zu dritt eigentlich spielen gerade?
Da macht das viel mehr Spaß.
Mein Gott, so ein Kick, ne?
Ach nee, die spielen gar nicht zu dritt, da eine guckt zu.
Okay, ich hab nix gesagt.
Die zeigen uns das doch jetzt nur...
Also was ist denn das auch für ein Monitor?
What the fuck, sind wir hier 1995 oder was?
Aber ganz davon abgesehen,
die zeigen doch jetzt absichtlich so ein Klopp-Dings-Spiel,
weil sie sagen können, hoho, gefährliche Prügelspiele oder so was.
In Wirklichkeit, realistisch betrachtet,
würden die eigentlich da sitzen und Fortnite spielen.
Oder was auch gerade Warzone oder so, was auch gerade angesagt ist.
Wenn ich Playstation spiele, werde ich schon aggressiv
und bin anders drauf, als ich sonst bin.
Und stimmt das?
Ja, ich merke das auch selber.
So ist das bei meinen Kindern auch.
Ich glaube besonders aggressiv ist er,
wenn in den Warzone irgendeinen Cheater weghaut.
Erschreckend, zumal man als Eltern irgendwann
wohl ganz die Einflussmöglichkeiten verliert.
Ich treffe einen Professor, der Gaming nicht verteufelt
und sogar noch Vorteile für Kinder darin sieht.
Sie würden ihre sozialen und kognitiven Fähigkeiten trainieren.
Videospielen bedeutet Problemlösen.
Und zwar kontinuierliches Problemlösen.
Sehr komplexe Informationen müssen in hoher Geschwindigkeit
verarbeitet werden, es müssen permanent Entscheidungen getroffen werden.
Gehe ich links, gehe ich rechts.
Hüpfen, ducken.
Das ist jetzt sehr vereinfacht ausgedrückt,
aber der hat nicht unrecht.
Man soll die Denkleistung, die dort erbracht wird,
nicht gering schätzen.
Das stimmt, man sieht es ja allein schon daran.
Ohne Scheiß.
Legt euch 5 Stunden hin und macht nichts.
Oder spielt 5 Stunden richtig intensiv was.
Nach den 5 Stunden intensiv irgendwelche PvP-Geschichten
oder irgendwelche Competitive-Sachen gespielt hast du Hunger.
Wenn du 5 Stunden gelegen hast und nichts gemacht, nicht.
Wo habe ich eigentlich mein 3-Head-Emote?
Wo ist denn das hin? Ich finde es nicht, Leute.
Leute, ihr müsst mir mal kurz helfen.
Ich finde meinen Emote nicht mehr.
Wir gucken sofort weiter.
Wo habe ich mein 3-Head-Emote?
Wo ist es? Seht ihr es irgendwo?
Wo ist es?
Da, da, ich habe es.
Okay, wo ist es? Hier?
Ich sehe es nicht.
Es ist neben Stonks. Ah, hier.
Das hängt halb aus dem Bildschirm raus.
Alles klar, okay.
Okay, wir können weiter gucken.
Spiele trainieren, komplexes Problem lösen.
Und sie sorgen dafür, dass junge Leute ihre grauen Zellen anstrengen.
Ja.
Und zwar häufig in einem höheren Maße,
als es die guten alten Schulaufgaben tun.
Warum?
Weil Videospiele Spaß machen.
Die jungen Leute wollen ihre grauen Zellen anstrengen.
Habt ihr euch schon mal gedacht, dass zu viel spielen,
dass das ein bisschen Zeitverschwendung ist?
Ja.
Ganz früher, ne?
Da sollte ich lernen, aber habe gespielt.
Das ist halt nicht so gut.
Könnte man lieber die Zeit und andere Sachen investieren,
die besser sind.
Die drei machen jetzt viel Sport.
Aber wenn sie von früher sprechen...
Das sagt er doch jetzt auch nur, weil sie ihn danach gefragt haben,
die vom Fernsehen da sind, oder?
Damals, vor allem der Typ ist 15.
Was ist denn damals?
Vor einem halben Jahr, oder wie?
Das ist übrigens ganz wichtig.
Es ist unglaublich wichtig,
dass sie im Zimmer alle eine Kappe aufhaben
und dann noch eine Sonnenbrille.
Ein paar Monate her.
Früher bin ich ehrlich.
Ich habe früher echt oft gespielt.
Richtig, richtig oft.
Nachtdurch und alles.
Daran habe ich auch gemerkt, das macht den Kopf nur kaputt.
Ich schlafe auch viel schlechter und alles.
Okay, das stimmt.
Der Schlafrhythmus ist richtig dann kaputt.
Das stimmt schon.
Das macht gar keinen Spaß.
Wenn man den ganzen Tag wirklich nur gesessen hat,
vorm Rechner oder vor der Konsol gespielt,
man hat das Problem,
dass man erstens permanent weiter
über das Game denkt.
Nachdenkt.
Dadurch, dass man sich nicht bewegt hat,
dass einem auch der körperliche Ausgleich fehlt.
Deswegen im Prinzip das machen,
was ich eben in meinem letzten Video
auf YouTube erzählt habe.
Da ging es zwar aufs Thema Stress.
Genau, da bist du
Vogue.
Vogue bist du dann.
Was ich erzählt habe.
Du musst dich einfach ein bisschen bewegen.
Das ist alles überhaupt nicht schlimm.
Es ist alles kacke.
Es ist fast alles kacke,
wenn du nichts anderes
den ganzen Tag machst als das.
Das kannst du eigentlich auch fast alles übertragen.
Wenn du den ganzen Tag nur eine Sache komplett machst
und dann wieder pennen gehst,
dann ist es in der Regel, egal was es ist,
eigentlich nicht gut.
Ist das so?
Okay.
Das machen Typen natürlich nicht.
Also nein.
Also das da ist Kati
und das da ist Lena.
Und du bist?
Das ist Roblox?
Ist das Roblox?
Am Computer.
Das Freizeitverhalten
hat sich von meiner zu ihrer Generation
ganz schön verändert.
In Wirklichkeit ist es so,
die Mädels sitzen hier
mit ihren Freunden.
Das ist nicht Discord.
Zoom wahrscheinlich oder so.
Und spielen Roblox.
Die Typen sitzen noch echt im Zimmer
und ballern ein bisschen.
Und realistisch betrachtet wäre es eigentlich so,
die Typen würden auch daheim sitzen,
hätten Discord an, Facetime, okay,
hätten Discord an und wären
keine Ahnung, im Montana Black Discord
würden die den ganzen Tag chillen normalerweise.
Oder ich weiß, sie hat dann überhaupt einen Discord.
Ich erfolge das nicht so.
Also das wäre eigentlich
eine realistische Variante.
Ich habe mit meinen Freundinnen noch echte Puppenhäuser
eingerichtet.
Alter Roblox,
was finden
die Leute eigentlich an Roblox?
Ich glaube, da bin ich zu Boomer für.
Alles, was ich von Roblox sehe, sieht
einfach extrem
abgefuckt billig
aus. So billig
sieht Roblox aus. Roblox sieht
aus, wie als hätte sich jemand
einen Unity
Editor aufgemacht
und einen Overlay Asset
Pack gekauft und hätte da drei
Dinge reintrack und droppt.
Roblox sieht alles
so unglaublich billig aus, was ich davon
sehe.
Das kann man dann halt
so lange machen, bis man mit
der Küche sozusagen zufrieden ist.
10-
bis 17-Jährige verbringen 5 oder 6
Stunden am Tag vorm Rechner.
Im Durchschnitt. Während des Lockdowns
kamen noch 75% dazu.
Ohne Homeschooling wohl
bemerkt. Reine Daddelzeit.
Ja und?
Was sollen Sie da
vor allem, gerade während Corona, was sollen
Sie denn sonst noch großartig machen?
Gegen die Wand gucken.
Seit 8 Wochen
erholt er sich auf der Jugendzuchtstation
im UKE. Wir
machen sein Gesicht unkenntlich.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ihr macht nicht sein Gesicht unkenntlich. Ihr filmt ihn
von hinten.
Okay, ich weiß, sie schwenken jetzt gleich rüber.
Ich habe sehr, sehr viele
Ego-Shooter gespielt, zum Beispiel
Apex, Call of Duty,
halt Ballerspiele
würde ich jetzt sagen, ja.
Ich wette mit euch, die haben das 5
Mal aufgenommen und haben jetzt das
dieses Ding
genommen, weil er das richtige Wort gesagt
hat.
Aber auch
kreative Spiele
oder Rennspiele.
Need for Speed, Forza Horizon
und das ja
teilweise 10, 12
Stunden, aber wenn es dann wirklich schlimm
war, auch mal 72 Stunden.
Was ist das dann? Also warum
kann man nicht aufhören, wenn man da
beginnt?
Ich stelle mir gerade vor 72 Stunden
Minecraft spielen.
Dann hätte ich aber auch Probleme danach.
Dann wäre ich auch
richtig, richtig dead.
Bei Destiny 2 zum Beispiel, da brauche ich
ja, da gibt es verschiedene Waffen,
die man sich erfahren kann.
Da braucht man dann 8 Stunden für.
Dann gibt es Raids, die man laufen kann.
Okay, da kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Ich habe nur mal ein paar Wochen
lang mit dem Fabian Ultra Casual
Destiny gespielt. Also Ultra Casual heißt, wir
haben 8 Stunden am Tag das Game durchgerusht,
bis wir dann keinen Bock mehr hatten.
Soviel zum Thema.
Wir haben das Addon
irgendwie in einem Tag durchgespielt, eineinhalb Tagen
oder was auch immer. Zumindest
ich kenne mich mit Destiny
nicht so großartig aus, muss ich sagen.
Aber war das nicht
so, dass in Destiny sogar der
mögliche Progress
stark beschränkt war
auf die Woche? Du musstest
den Tag abwarten, wann der Händler
da ist. Du konntest dir nur irgendwie so
viele Dinge kaufen die Woche. Du konntest
das nur so und so oft machen.
War das eigentlich nicht
in Destiny eher so, dass
sich der ultra hardcore Crime
gar nicht richtig gelohnt hat in Destiny?
Zumindest ist das so mein Eindruck gewesen.
Na gut, 6-7 Stunden ist ja an sich
kein Problem.
Spielen von Videospielen wird Suchterzeug
dadurch, dass man nicht immer
belohnt wird, wenn man was richtig macht.
Wenn man jemanden tot schießt oder irgendwas
anderes, wofür es Punkte
gibt, erhält.
Sondern man erhält nur dann Punkte,
wenn der Zufall auch noch mitentscheidet.
Und diese gleichzeitig sozusagen
durch die eigene Aktion ermöglichte,
aber dann erst per Zufall gesteuerte
Zuweisung von Belohnung. Das ist
das, was am süchtigsten macht. Das wissen
wir. Spielen für ein Glücksgefühl,
das immer schwerer zu erreichen ist. Da ist schon was dran.
Wer aufhört, verliert alles
bereits Erreichte.
Ein enormer sozialer Druck.
Lukas wollte sein Online-Team nicht
im Stich lassen. Einmal alle 2 Wochen bin
ich zum Arzt gefahren, um mir eine Krankmeldung zu holen.
Ja, aber
sonst bestand halt nur das Zocken.
Ich saß nur in meinem Zimmer, meistens
dunkel. Man verliert den Kontakt
zu anderen Menschen. Ich habe
irgendwann Probleme gekriegt, dann wirklich was mit anderen
zu machen, weil ich Angst davor hatte.
Online ist es nämlich viel einfacher.
Ich habe auch Probleme mit anderen Menschen,
was zu machen. Das liegt aber daran, weil ich anderen Menschen
in der Regel absolut nicht abkann.
Man sieht die
Mimik und die Gestik der anderen
Leute nicht. Man hört eigentlich nur die Reaktion
übers Headset dann.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber
weiß ich.
Also
vor allem, warum muss da eigentlich
ausgeblurrt werden? Ist das jetzt so
ein Kniff
vom Fernsehsender,
dass das irgendwie spektakulärer aussieht
oder wollte er das wirklich nicht?
Ich meine, ich will gar nicht bestreiten, dass
es solche Fälle gibt, wo das wirklich
ernsthaft
auf das Leben so große Auswirkungen
hat, dass sie nicht mehr,
die Doku ist von vor zwei Wochen oder so,
dass sie nicht mehr ihr normales
Leben leben können. Ich kenne da sogar auch Leute,
die damals,
ich muss jetzt leider das Beispiel bringen, weil
ich habe da jetzt in letzter Zeit
WTF, wie eine Erfahrung drin,
die in World of Warcraft teilweise ihren Job
verloren haben. Das war ja
wirklich so eines der Dinge,
ich glaube, das kennt jeder irgendeinen.
Also wenn ihr in dieser Zeit aufgewachsen,
wachsend seid,
kennt jeder mindestens irgendeinen, der mit
World of Warcraft, was weiß ich, von Frau,
Freundin bis Job irgendwas verloren hat, weil das
richtig verkackt hat. Das war ja fast
schon Standard.
Klar kann das
wirklich Probleme verursachen.
Aber was ich
bei diesen Dokus immer ein bisschen doof finde,
ist, dass da so mit dieser
Einstellung drangegangen wird, ne, das muss ich anders
sagen, dass da halt mit den Voraussetzungen
des letzten Jahrtausends drangegangen wird.
Das ist dann
von Leuten für Leute,
die mit Leuten reden,
die quasi da überhaupt keinen Bezug zu haben
und die über Leute reden,
die ja für sie
quasi fast schon in einer anderen Welt
sind. Also, das kann man...
Die gehen immer in die gleiche Richtung.
Aber wir gucken jetzt mal weiter.
Dass der Typ jetzt vielleicht wirklich ernsthafte
Probleme hat, will ich gar nicht bestreiten.
Kann schon sein.
Und ja, oder wenn man dann wirklich mit
Gestik und Mimik dann konfrontiert wird, ist das schwer.
Man hat dann irgendwann Angst davor.
Wisst ihr, was ich jetzt ohne Scheiß
verlernt hab? Jetzt muss ich mal sagen, eine Sache,
die sich bei mir, die ich nicht durch die
spiele, sondern die ich durch, weil ich jetzt quasi
seit, ja was weiß ich,
bin jetzt
37, sagen wir mal seit 20
Jahren, 20, 23
Jahren oder so,
sehr viel vom PC. Wisst ihr, was ich wirklich
verlernt habe?
Ich habe verlernt, mit der Hand
Schreibschrift
flüssig zu schreiben. Kann ich nicht mehr.
Ich kann nicht mehr, ich kann schon noch
schreiben mit der Hand, das ist kein Problem.
Ich kann Sachen ausfüllen und so, das ist kein Ding.
Aber so Schreibschrift, wie man sie in der
Schule gelernt hat,
das kann ich nicht.
Ich kann nur
Schreibschrift schreiben.
Also ohne
Scheiß, ich
fülle
mittlerweile
alles in Schreibschrift aus.
Du durftest nicht mehr Schreibschrift schreiben.
Also ich kann das nicht mehr.
Also wenn ich
irgendwie was ausfülle,
dann schreibe ich wirklich dann hin
Max.
So, na jetzt vielleicht nicht so.
Aber früher, ich überlege gerade, wie sah das
überhaupt aus Schreibschrift?
Irgendwie so?
Ich kann das nicht mehr.
Ich kann das
nicht mehr.
Ich habe das verlernt.
Also wenn einer wirklich
von mir will, dass ich mal was längeres
von Hand schreibe, dann bin ich richtig lost.
Wenn mich dann konfrontiert wird, ist das schwer.
Man hat dann irgendwann Angst davor.
Sein Kind im Netz zu verlieren,
der Horror aller Eltern.
Das meine ich auch.
Im Netz zu verlieren? Alter,
was eine Aussage. Ist es dann weg?
Guckst du...
Das hört sich jetzt so an, wie
dein Kind geht nach dem Mittagessen ins Kinderzimmer
und dann gehst du
zwei Stunden später hoch und guckst
ins Kinderzimmer hoch. Wo ist es hin?
Mod-Check.
Es ist weg.
Es ist einfach nicht mehr da.
Das Ventil im Hintergrund
stünden immer auch andere Schwierigkeiten.
Nicht jeder
hat übermäßige Gebrauch.
Hat tatsächlich auch Krankheitswert.
Es kann sehr gut angehen,
dass in pubertären
Problemlagen
die Jugendlichen exzessive Spielverhalten
aufzeigen
über Wochen oder auch über Monate.
Dass sich aber auch ohne jede
Intervention wieder
zurückbilden würde, weil
die nicht
schwer beeinträchtigten Jugendlichen
merken, dass übermäßige
Spielverhalten sie in anderen
Lebensbereichen einschränkt.
Also ich spiele bei weitem nicht mehr so viel wie früher
mittlerweile.
Mag aber auch zum größten Teil
daran liegen, dass es weniger Games gibt,
wo ich mich so richtig reinsteigern kann.
Also bei den meisten
Leuten regelt sich das alles
von allein.
Gehe ich jetzt von aus.
Als süchtig
gilt, wer die Kontrolle über
die Spieldauer verloren hat.
Über 12 Monate hinweg
müssen soziale Kontakte, Hobbys
und die Schule dann niederliegen.
Erst dann ist es Sucht.
Ich finde das krass.
Und Lukas ist nur einer.
Moment, was ist daran krass?
Die sagt ja quasi,
sie findet es krass.
Also es muss erst
richtig harte Auswirkungen haben,
dass es als Sucht gilt. Ja, was denn sonst?
Wenn ich was
mache und parallel alles
andere zufriedenstellend erledige,
verwende ich ja wohl genug Zeit
auf die wichtigen Sachen. Warum ist es
krass, wenn es dann erst als Sucht
gilt?
Über 12 Monate
hinweg müssen soziale Kontakte,
Hobbys und die Schule dann
niederliegen. Erst dann ist es
Sucht. Was denn sonst?
Was denn sonst?
Wenn du alles auf die Reihe kriegst,
trotz 5 Stunden Spielen am Tag,
dann ist es ja wohl alles kein Problem.
Du magst
vielleicht süchtig sein nach
irgendwie einem Spiel, aber du
hast es zumindest in so weit im Griff,
dass nicht dein restliches Leben
darunter leidet.
Man kennt ja jeder,
es kommt ein neues Game raus,
was ihr super nice findet,
und ihr sitzt dann auf der Arbeit und denkt euch,
ah,
ich würde mich am liebsten jetzt
einloggen und weiterspielen, aber ihr macht das nicht.
Es ist erst so richtig
Hardcore-Sucht, wenn ihr sagt, okay,
ich gehe heute nicht auf die Arbeit, weil ich
spielen will. Das ist ja was anderes.
Und wenn man das nicht macht, dann ist es auch
keine Sucht oder zumindest nicht
krankhaft. Das ist ja das eigentliche Problem.
Und da sehe ich überhaupt kein Problem drin.
Ich finde das krass.
Wahnsinnig krass. Und Lucas ist nur einer von 700.000
Kindern und Jugendlichen in Deutschland.
Richtig krass. Die Leute machen was,
was ihnen Spaß macht,
was sie irgendwie erfüllt und was keine negativen
Auswirkungen auf ihr Leben hat.
Krass. Alter, richtig krass.
Muss verboten werden.
Mit so einem pathologischen Medienkonsum.
Aber was ist es, was Kinder so fasziniert?
Ihr Gehirn ist
noch im Wachstum und dadurch besonders
anfällig für Verführungen.
Da die Impulskontrolle noch nicht ganz
ausgebildet ist, sind sie Versuchungen
wie Computerspielen fast hilflos
ausgeliefert.
Das würden wir jetzt auch nicht besser machen.
Und dennoch. Medien
sind fester Bestandteil ihrer Wirklichkeit.
Nicht erst seit der
Pandemie wird die Digitalisierung
im Unterricht vorangetrieben.
Ist ja auch wichtig.
Sogar erste Kitas in Deutschland
setzen bereits auf digitale Bildung.
Zum Beispiel dieser
Kindergarten. Ich könnte das nie
machen. Ich glaube, also generell
Arbeiten mit Menschen wäre für mich der Horror.
Arbeiten mit Kindern
als Kindergärtner, das wäre ja...
Also, weiß nicht,
da würde ich mich glaube ich aus dem Fenster
stürzen, wenn ich das machen müsste.
Das wäre vorbei, das würde ich
nicht ertragen.
Ich finde es geil, dass es Leute gibt, die so was machen können.
Wirklich Hut ab, dass man das
aushält.
Ich könnte mir das bloß einfach nicht vorstellen.
StriveSole7 sagt, könnte das.
Ich finde es super, ich finde es wirklich nice, dass es Leute gibt.
Ich könnte das nicht. Das wäre für mich nicht
möglich.
Die Medienkompetenz, die wollen mir fördern
und wollen mir den Kindern beibringen, dass Medien
nicht immer nur Spaß ist, sondern wir haben
auch einen kritischen Blick.
Wenn der Internetausbau in Deutschland schon nicht funktioniert...
Im Endeffekt
sollen die Kinder auch schon auf die Zukunft
vorbereitet werden, weil spätestens in der
Grundschule geht es dann los.
Und wenn die Kinder dann schon durch die
Kiefer-Vor-Erfahrung haben, ist natürlich der
Einstieg in der Schule einfacher.
Ist das ein Tablet?
Ist das ein Tablet, was irgendwie so
einen Gummi-Einband hat, dass es nicht kaputt
geht, wenn man sich auf den Kopf haut oder so?
Wahrscheinlich eher, wenn man es runterschmeißt.
So lange, bis der Bild schon einspringt.
Einen ganz normalen,
unkompetenten Umgang sollen die Kinder
hier verinnerlichen. Mit Erfolg
sagt die Kita. Tablets hätten
ganz schnell ihre Suche verloren
und nun nur noch den gleichen Reiz
wie Bauklötze.
Ich glaube, dass es sinnvoll ist, auch im Kindergarten
digitale Medien zu
thematisieren, auch den Umgang damit.
Die sind richtig hip.
Die schreiben den ersten Buchstaben kleiner als den zweiten.
...zu ermöglichen, weil sie eben
Bestandteil jener Lebenswelt
sein werden, die unseren Kindern
in der Zukunft bevorstehen wird.
Aber müssen Kita-Kinder
wirklich schon Spielzeug programmieren
und wissen, wie sie digitale Fotos
bearbeiten? Ja, warum nicht?
Warum nicht? Für mich gehört ein Tablet-Diplom
nicht zwingend zu einer glücklichen Kindheit.
Warum denn nicht?
Wo ist denn das Problem?
Das ist doch gut, wenn die Kinder nicht komplett
weltfremd in der aktuellen
Zeit aufwachsen.
Die Kinder müssen kein C++ lernen.
Ja, okay.
Es gibt eine Menge Studien.
Also Kinder
C++ beibringen im Kindergarten würde
ich tatsächlich nicht machen, dann ist kein Wunder,
wenn die ihr Leben nicht auf die Reihe kriegen.
Danach ist vorbei.
Aber dass man im Kindergarten schon
Umgang lernt mit
Fotobearbeitung und Tablets und so was,
das finde ich vollkommen
gerechtfertigt.
Das ist doch
sinnvoll.
Du kannst doch,
die Zeiten ändern sich halt.
Die Kinder heute wachsen
nicht mehr so auf wie ich.
Keine Ahnung, bis 13,
14 hatte ich keinen Rechner.
Warte mal, lass ich mal rechnen.
Ja, so, ich glaube,
ne, 98 hatte ich schon,
Huff Life, Huff Life, vor 96
hatte ich also, sprich,
12, 13,
bis 12, 13 hatte ich keinen Rechner.
Ich habe das gemacht, was man damals
von den Kindern, wie man das sich
auch denkt. Ich bin viel draußen
rumgerannt,
hab mich beim Fahrradfahren verletzt
oder was auch immer. Aber die Zeiten sind
halt anders. Heute ist halt nicht mal
1984 oder 1990, sondern
heute ist 2021.
Für mich gehört ein Tabletdiplom nicht
zwingend zu einer glücklichen Kindheit.
Es gibt eine Menge
Studien, die gezeigt haben,
dass digitale Medien das tun, was sie immer tun,
nämlich ablenken. Und wenn man
beim Lernen abgelenkt ist, lernt man weniger.
Dann wird immer argumentiert, na ja, aber ich muss doch
wissen, wie die funktionieren. Nun, die sind heute so einfach,
dass jedes Baby sie verwenden kann.
Ich muss das also nicht wissen.
Dann wird argumentiert, wir brauchen Medienkompetenz,
damit man Fake News von Nicht-Fake News unterscheiden kann.
Völliger Blödsinn, weil sie
können Wahrheit von Falschheit
nicht durch irgendeine allgemeine Fähigkeit unterscheiden.
Die gibt's gar nicht. Sie können
nur Vorwissen haben. Und je mehr sie wissen,
auf einem Gebiet, ich zum Beispiel in der Medizin,
dann kann ich sehr schnell sagen, das ist Blödsinn und das taugt was.
Weil ich Ahnung von Medizin habe,
nicht weil ich Medienkompetenz habe.
Das würde mich jetzt mal
interessieren, wie ihr da drauf kommt.
Also, das
erste Gegenbeispiel,
das erste Gegenbeispiel,
was mir dazu einfällt,
ist, dass man
sehr wohl zum Beispiel lernen kann, wie man Suchmaschinen
bedient. Und man merkt
den Unterschied zwischen Leuten,
die das geübt haben, bzw. wissen, wie sie schnell
Sachen über eine Suchmaschine finden
und anhand der Suchergebnisse schon direkt
einschätzen können, welche Seiten was taugen,
welche nicht.
Also, das ist...
Das merkst du, ob das jemand
geübt hat, ob da jemand Erfahrungen drin hat.
Und du kannst auch
ziemlich gut im Internet...
Also, sag ich jetzt,
ich meine, vielleicht dauert das eine Weile,
ziemlich gut dazwischen unterscheiden,
was Scam ist und was
nicht Scam ist. Was meint ihr denn, warum so
viele Leute auf irgendwelchen sinnlosen
Scams im Internet reinfallen? Weil sie
Kacknoobs sind, weil sie keine Ahnung haben,
was da Sache ist. Die bekommen eine Mail
von Sparkasse.de
und denken sich, hoho,
die Sparkasse möchte mein Passwort kontrollieren.
Nein, die Sparkasse will nicht dein
Passwort kontrollieren. Das ist irgendein China-Chinesen-
Scammer, der dann Passwort kontrollieren will.
Also, ich frag mich, wie er da drauf kommt.
Der hat sicherlich in...
Im Großen
Gesamten nicht Unrecht,
wenn er sagt, das Medien ablenken.
Aber das kannst du nicht so pauschal
damit irgendwie wegbügeln.
Naja.
Spiele wie Call of Duty
kosten 70 Euro und mehr.
Und mehr. Und mehr.
Der amerikanische Entwickler verdient aber auch viel Geld
durch Zusatzinhalte, die die Spieler
sich runterladen können.
Damals haben wir vor allem...
Also, wir haben viel
Geld in Spielen eininvestiert.
Ja, sehr viel Geld.
Und das beruhe ich jetzt.
Okay. Investiert ist vielleicht
der falsche Begriff dafür.
Investieren bedeutet ja,
er schattet das Geld da reingesteckt,
und er bekommt da irgendwie mal was raus.
Das ist, glaube ich, bei Call of Duty der falsche Begriff.
Natürlich wissen wir,
was er meint. Und ja, das ist ein Problem.
Das finde ich auch nicht gerade sinnvoll.
Das versucht wird den Leuten quasi immer
mehrfach zwei- bis dreimal
für das Spiel Geld aus der Tasche zu ziehen.
Das ist auch... Was ich halt
da drum... Was ich da halt dumm
dran finde, ist, dass die Spiele dadurch
meistens nicht besser werden.
Dass die Spiele...
Bestes Beispiel ist das letzte Star Wars
Game, wo Helden drin waren,
wo du hättest, glaube ich, irgendwie vier Monaten für
grinden müssen, aber du hättest es ja auch kaufen können.
Bis jetzt immer noch.
Weil mit diesem Geld konnte ich mir echt
richtig gute Klamotten holen.
Also, da war schon unnötiges Geld
für Playstation auszugeben.
Locker 1000 Euro oder so.
Locker, wenn schon.
Okay, der Witz ist ja,
dass die Klamotten und
Sachen für das Game genau aus dem
gleichen Grund ausgeben.
Das ist denen, glaube ich, gar nicht so klar.
Sie geben in-Game Geld
für Call of Duty aus, weil sie dann krassen
Dark Matter-Skin oder was auch immer am Start
haben. Und sie geben, weil sie dann
in-Game auf dicke Hose
machen können. Und sie geben
Geld im Re-Life aus, weil sie sich
irgendwie, weiß nicht, was ist gerade so angesachte
Klamottenmarke, keine Ahnung, anziehen können.
Gucci-Cap.
Weil sie da auf
dicke Hose machen können. Der Grund, warum
die Geld reinstecken, ist genau das
gleiche. Quasi
Status in
einer gewissen Gruppe.
Und ich bin mir mal gar nicht sicher, ob
man jetzt sagen kann, dass es
prinzipiell besser ist für eine
Gucci-Cap.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was sowas kostet denn sowas.
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Vor allem sieht das vom Muster aus,
als hätte das mein Opa mal auf gehabt,
Alter.
Hey,
dann gebe ich lieber 30
Euro für einen Season Pass aus.
Dann sind es wahrscheinlich
China-Chinesen-Fakes,
ja. Aber
ich würde mal gar nicht so sehr sagen,
wer bestimmt denn bitteschön, wer
bestimmt das, wer legt fest,
dass es sinnvoll ist,
eine Gucci-Cap zu kaufen, für
quasi Re-Life-Status
in seiner
bekannten Gruppe.
Dass das irgendwie besser ist, als
sich den Season Pass für Dark Matter
Tarnung zu kaufen.
Wer legt das fest?
Letztendlich sollte es doch darum
gehen, wo er für sich persönlich
quasi die,
sag mal mal, wie soll was sein denn so, die
größere Erfüllung daraus
hat. Und wenn das bei einem der
Dark Matter-Skin ist,
dann meinetwegen der Dark Matter-Skin.
Und wenn der anderen richtig krass da,
aber ist das eine Gucci-Cap?
Das sieht, das, guck mal, das sieht auch
wirklich so aus. Habt ihr das?
Was wollt ihr von mir?
Das sieht auch so aus.
Ja, okay, also wenn der Typ
sich für 350 Euro
eine Kappe, oder für 300 Euro
eine Kappe kaufen kann, dann hat er, glaub ich, auch keine
Probleme, sich den aktuellen Season Pass
zu leisten. Gut, mal ehrlich gesagt,
er hat's wahrscheinlich gekauft, sein Eltern haben's
wahrscheinlich gekauft.
Ja, ja, das hab ich ja schon
gesagt. Das sehe ich generell bei Spielen
auch als Problem. Und es gibt ja nicht
umsonst genug Länder, die sagen, hey,
diese klassische Lootbox-Mechanik
wollen sie nicht mehr dulden.
Mein Problem damit ist hauptsächlich, dass die Spiele
dadurch schlechter werden und ich irgendwie
frech finde, dass Spielehersteller
versuchen mittlerweile bei einem Vollpreisspiel,
also dass es mittlerweile etabliert
ist, FIFA ist das beste Beispiel,
dass es mittlerweile schon bei manchen Marken
oder bei immer mehr etabliert ist, dass
ein Vollpreisspiel die
Leute 2,
3, 4, 5 mal zur
Kasse bittet.
Die haben sich da aber auch genau die richtigen
Kandidaten ausgesucht, oder?
Die haben sich da genau die richtigen
Leute
zu diesem Beitrag ausgesucht.
Die so quasi,
wenn jemand diesen Beitrag sieht, stellt euch
mal vor, wenn sich jetzt Eltern,
die eh schon quasi da Panik schieben,
hilfe mein Kind,
ich verliere mein Kind an das
Internet. So, wenn
die diesen Beitrag sehen,
dann die drei Halbstarken,
die hocken gesehen,
plus das Gelaber von denen,
da wird dann alles bestätigt,
was die für Ängste haben.
Da haben sie sich auch wirklich die richtigen Spezialisten
rausgesucht hier.
Oder in FIFA
zum Beispiel kaufe ich mir so FIFA Packs
und mit dem Packs kann ich halt Karten
ziehen, die richtig gut sind, dann habe ich ein besseres Team als
die anderen.
FIFA Packs, ja.
FIFA Packs ist auch der größte Shit überhaupt.
Und in die Gucci Cap.
Darf man nicht vergessen, ey,
die Kappe hat wahrscheinlich so viel gekostet
wie 30 Packs.
Viele Spieleentwickler arbeiten offenbar
mit einer Menge perfider Tricks.
Du Hund!
Ich konfrontiere den Verband der Deutschen
Gamesbronchen mit dem Vorwurf.
Digga!
Wir nehmen das auch sehr ernst, wir haben zum Beispiel
mehrere Tochterunternehmen
und Institutionen, die wir auch mitfinanzieren.
Das ist einmal die USK, die kümmert sich den ganzen Tag
um Jugendschutz
und wir haben auch
eine Institution, die heißt
die Stiftung Digitale Spielekultur
und die macht ganz viel im Bereich Pädagogik
und Medienkompetenz. Zum Schluss ist
ein Dreiklang, ist ja eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe, das heißt
gerade beim Thema Jugendschutz, da sind Unternehmen
gefragt, da ist aber auch der Staat und die öffentlichen
Institutionen gefragt und als drittes natürlich
die Eltern. Die Gaming-Industrie
verhält sich etwa so wie die Drogen-
Mafia. Sie schadet
eine Menge. Der erschreckt aber auch nicht
davor zurück, immer die dicksten
Geschütze aufzufahren, oder?
Da ist natürlich schon was
dran, aber der kommt da immer
mit Dingern um die Ecke, Alter!
Junge, jungen Menschen und profitiert
davon. Statt staatlicher Kontrolle
Elternpflicht, doch viele scheinen
überfordert, denn
50% der Eltern machen ihren Kindern
keine zeitlichen Einschränkungen
und 33% beaufsichtigen
das Problem. Aber ganz
im Ernst, zeitlich einschränkend.
Das Hauptproblem ist, wenn du solche
das kann ich jetzt nur
von mir Schluss folgern.
Natürlich
hatten wir auch Diskussionen mit
wie viel vom Rechner
und hin und her und für
keine Ahnung, für
eine gute Note in der Schule, irgendwie
dann auch abends
länger vom Rechner und so. Ich glaube
solche Sachen
das hat jeder mal irgendwie gehabt
oder hat das immer
noch.
Zumindest das Problem an zeitlichen
Einschränkungen ist ja eher, dass
zeitliche Einschränkungen eigentlich hauptsächlich
die Kreativität fördern, wie man
diese zeitlichen Einschränkungen umgehen kann.
Das heißt, du verwendest
dann nicht etwa die Zeit dafür
in Sicht der
Eltern sinnvolle Dinge zu machen,
du verwendest dann die Zeit eher darauf
dir Gedanken zu machen,
ja entweder was du machst, wenn du wieder
an den Rechner kommst und gammelst halt den ganzen Tag
rum, bis du an den Rechner darfst, oder gehst
zu irgendeinem Freund nach der Schule, wo ihr spielen darfst.
Sonst hat es also im Prinzip die Kreativität für
darauf verwendet zu gucken, wie man das Ganze
irgendwie umschiffen kann.
Natürlich finde ich es auch nicht
sinnvoll, wenn man jetzt sagt,
ok,
was weiß ich, Kind
kommt von der Schule um
zwölf, was weiß ich, aber der Kind
noch in die Grundschule, kommt von zwölf von der Schule
und würde dann irgendwie bis 22 Uhr
Fortnite spielen oder so. Das fände ich auch
nicht gerade sinnvoll. Da muss ich
sagen, das ist natürlich auch
sicherlich nicht der Weisheitsletzter
Schluss.
Naja,
gucken wir mal weiter, was jetzt kommt.
Was schon der Buchtitel
nach einer halben Stunde ist Schluss.
Ich sehe es jetzt nirgendwo, wo das steht,
aber in einer halben Stunde hast du ja heutzutage
noch nicht bei deinem Rechner und alle möglichen
Clients
gestartet.
Die mediale Kompetenz
vieler Eltern ist schlecht.
Sie können überhaupt gar nicht
nachfolgen. Moment, das stimmt nicht.
Wir haben gerade vom Spitzer gehört,
man braucht keine Medienkompetenz.
Man braucht
Erfahrung in diesem Gebiet.
Medienkompetenz, Fake News.
Das kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Das hat
damit alles nichts zu tun.
Das hat damit alles nichts zu tun.
Das haben wir eben gerade gehört.
Michael, 50 Billionen. Danke für den Sub.
Wichtig aus meiner Sicht ist,
dass die Eltern versuchen mal so ein bisschen
dahinter zu steigen, was da eigentlich
abgeht. Also sprich, dass man
mal versucht halbwegs zu verstehen, was die
Kinder da eigentlich machen.
Also wenn ich Kinder hätte und
also gut, sagen wir mal, ich hätte vor, als
sie noch angesagt waren, vor, keine Ahnung, ich hätte
irgendwie vor 10 Jahren, wie gesagt
mit 37, mit 27 wäre das
kein Problem gewesen, ich meine, ich habe vor 10 Jahren Kinder gekriegt
und ihr habt gesehen, die hätten alle Snapchat am Start.
Ich habe bis heute nicht
Snapchat verwendet, aber ihr könnt von ausgehen, hätte ich
Kinder die Snapchat verwendet,
dann hätte ich mir das auch mal angeguckt.
Dann habe ich gesagt, ok, was ist denn das? Ich bin zwar
hauptsächlich so Twitter
User, aber
ich gucke mir das wenigstens mal an.
Also das größte Problem daran ist ja
quasi eher so das Desinteresse an den
Dingern, was die Kinder machen. Und
dann muss man sich auch nicht wundern,
wenn man als Eltern nicht durchblickt,
was da eigentlich passiert.
Nicht nur limitieren, sondern verstehen,
was man, also ich,
verbietet. Das würde ich auch so
sagen. Heißt, auch mal gemeinsam mit den Kindern zocken.
Die sind aber
oldschool hier.
Das ist ja mal
2005.
Einsam mit den Kindern zocken
und dann von Anfang an Grenzen
ziehen und immer am Ball bleiben.
Auch wenn es wahnsinnig viel
Kraft kostet. Also ich habe einen Kollege
auf der Arbeit, dem fällt mir jetzt eigentlich als Beispiel ganz
gut ein, der hat einen Sohn, der ist glaube ich
8 und
der
spielt beispielsweise auch gerne Minecraft.
In dem Alter.
Zehn ist der.
Ich glaube 8.
So in dem Dreh. 8, 9, 10.
Und der spielt gerne Minecraft.
Und die spielen zusammen Minecraft.
Spielt der Vater
mit seinem Kind Minecraft.
Das finde ich das Beste, was wir machen können.
Vermutlich ist es,
wie immer, ein Kompromiss
zwischen beiden Extremen.
Ich finde besonders vor der Nutzung
durch Kinder und Jugendliche, weil
deren Gehirne eben noch im Entstehen sind.
Und deswegen, was wir da falsch machen.
Also jetzt habt ihr es gehört, der halbe Kopf
ist leer. Dann auch falsch und ist nicht mehr
veränderbar. Und das macht mir wirklich
große Sorgen. Grundsätzlich
ist meine Haltung zum Videospielen
bei jungen Leuten erstmal, dass wir
optimistisch sein sollen, dass wir die Vorteile, die das
hat für Entwicklung, für Wohlbefinden
anerkennen, wertschätzen sollten,
bevor wir über die Probleme reden.
Da haben sie sich echt
die drei Spezialisten rausgesucht, ey.
Sag mal, haben die alle drei so eine 300 Euro
Gucci-Kappe auf? Guck mal, das ist doch
genau der gleiche Kram hier.
Und dann in der Mitte noch der Adidas
Jogging-Anzug.
Beste. Da haben sie sich echt
Spezialisten für rausgesucht für das Video.
Habe ich auch so einen Löffel für eine Panade,
Alter.
Brauchst du einen Chapman zu lesen?
Das ist ein Zülfall.
Sehr gut.
Der denkt halt in dem Alter, wenn man so ein bisschen
aggressiv rummacht, das wäre besonders
männlich und zieht die Mädels
an oder so. Und die Gucci-Kappe natürlich auch.
Oh man, naja, also der Beitrag
ist wieder so ein typischer öffentlich-rechtlicher
Anti-Gamer-Beitrag
gewesen.
Der eigentlich nichts anderes machen soll,
wie die Zielgruppe der öffentlich-rechtlichen,
nämlich irgendwelche 40,
50 plus jährigen Eltern
oder vielleicht sogar Großeltern,
die quasi Angst um ihre Kinder haben,
durch das böse Internet und aktuelle Spiele
darin zu bestätigen.
Das sehe ich jetzt nicht sonderlich.
Also das hat mich jetzt nicht
in irgendeiner Art und Weise überzeugt.
Für so einen Mist bezahlt man
Rundfunkgebühren. Naja, man bezahlt
Rundfunkgebühren auch für sehr viel mehr Mist.
Es gibt durchaus
sinnvolle Sachen im öffentlich-rechtlichen,
wo ich sage, hey, dafür kann man auch mal
Rundfunkgebühren bezahlen.
Ich überleg grad was.
Gibt's aber.
Aber ich guck so wenig Fernsehen.
Ich guck eigentlich gar nichts mehr.
Ja, doch.
Was ich cool finde ist,
was ich auf YouTube immer gucke,
ist so Handwerksendungen.
Wie heißt denn das?
So der letzte Schuhmacher von
irgendeinem Stadt
oder so.
Wie heißt das denn?
Wahres für Wahres ist teilweise
ja, kann man jetzt auch angucken.
Ich hab vergessen,
wie heißt das?
Handwerkskunst, genau.
Das guck ich mir immer, ich glaub, vom SWR.
Ja, das guck ich mir
immer gern zum Einschlafen an.
SWR.
Das heißt ernsthaft
SWR Craftsmanship?
Nee, ich glaube, YouTube hat das mir grade
übersetzt, oder?
Das guck ich mir gerne zum Einschlafen an.
Da hast du dann irgendwelche Leute, die
Fässer bauen oder so, das find ich cool.
Dafür geb ich auch Gebühren aus.
Dafür bezahl ich auch Gebühren.
Die sind neu, die sind auf jeden Fall neu.
Die sind 16 zu 9.000
80p, die sind nicht vor 20 Jahren gedreht.
Vor 20 Jahren, da war
Fernseh teilweise noch 4 zu 3.
Die machen schon
durchaus sinnvolle Sachen im Öffentlich-Rechtlichen.
Was ich halt, also
eine Sache mit dem Rundfunkbeitrag ist.
Ich finde das sinnvoll, dass es
öffentlich-rechtliche Sender gibt. Und ich finde, es gibt auch
im öffentlich-rechtlichen
Programmsachen, wo ich
sage, ja, das ist cool,
das bezahle ich gerne für.
Was mir nicht gefällt
beim öffentlich-rechtlichen, ist, dass es
so unglaublich ausufernd
ist. Wir haben, was weiß ich,
35 verschiedene Radiosender,
30 Milliarden
Dingern, die gemacht werden. Zum größten
Teil werden die Beiträge eh dafür benutzt,
um die Rente zu bezahlen von den Leuten, die früher
mal beim öffentlich-rechtlichen gearbeitet
haben. Also
ich hätte kein Problem damit
Rundfunkgebühren zu bezahlen.
Aber man könnte für sich vielleicht mal
überlegen,
ob man das nicht reduziert
oder zumindest, dass man sagt, hey,
man verschlankt das Programm
etwas. Weil da ist aus meinig schon
unglaublich viel Überflüssiges
dabei.
Natürlich, ja, du hast das Problem,
du hast das Problem, dass das natürlich nicht
nur ich, dass natürlich nicht das nur ich
entscheiden kann. Was ich überflüssig finde,
finden andere sinnvoll. Aber es gibt schon
viel, es gibt schon richtig
viel Stuss.
Ähm...
Musikantendampfer
oder sowas zum Beispiel.
Das braucht
glaube ich keiner.
Ähm...
Oder irgendwelche Trittklassiken
Comedy-Sendungen, die mega unlustig
sind. Und 35 Radiosender
braucht auch keiner.
Du brauchst nicht
einen Schlager-Radiosender
im Norden,
in der Mitte, im Süden, im Osten und
im Westen ein. Die können auch ruhig
ein Radiosender machen für Schlager,
wenn das so sein muss.
Also da gibt's sicherlich
auch, wenn man sich alles,
der Vielfalt halber anguckt,
einiges, wo man sagen
könnte, ok, das ist doppelt gemoppelt und das
braucht man eigentlich nicht.
Musik
So, schauen wir mal.
Was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Musik
Ok, wir lassen uns von Levelcap
chibane.
Eine Sekunde
von Levelcap
chibane lassen.
Musik
Ich darf dazu leider nichts sagen, weil ich muss
mittlerweile wieder eine NDA unterschreiben,
da ich nichts sage.
Deswegen ist es aber Levelcap weiß schon Bescheid.
Musik
Aber ich kann euch so viel sagen,
lang dauert's nicht mehr. Und ich bin
wirklich sehr gespannt, was uns die nächsten
Wochen bringen.
Musik
Zumal das Datum
ja mittlerweile offiziell ist.
Musik
Ich darf's...
Ich glaub, das darf ich werden. Ich darf's vorher schon spielen.
Musik
Meine RGB-LED-Hausnummern sind auch mittlerweile da, komplett ohne Zoll und alles, hat sich gelohnt.
Und falls das jemand jetzt zum ersten hört, ja, ich hab mir Hausnummern gekauft, in die man RGB-LED-Streifen reinmachen kann.
... oder Temporal-Bans. Und sie werden auch nicht nur Accounts gebannt. Bans werden auch deine IP-Adresse und das Hardware entdecken.
Der Beta-Trailer sah sehr gut aus und ich kann mich nicht auf das Spiel halten. Bleibt auf die In-Depth-Kurve der Beta.
Now aside from Battlefield 2042, EA are making some significant changes. Internally, long-time CFO Blake Jorgensen is leaving the Publisher next summer. He served as both the company's CFO and COO since 2012.
EA are promoting the... No, die Nummern hab ich noch nicht angebracht. Die Nummern basteln wir im Stream zusammen. Das waren deutsche... Jaja, du kannst in Battlefield 2042 gibt es so einen Custom-Mode, also gibt es so einen Modus-Designer.
Wo du die Assets drinne hast von Battlefield 3, Battlefield 1942 und was war das andere?
Battlefield 3, BC 2, BC 2, BF 3 und 1942.
Da kannst du so Custom Spielmodi zusammenbauen wo du dann beispielsweise auch mit den Uniformen
rumläufst.
Achso, die ist 22 Jahre da, ich wollte grad sagen die sieht nicht aus wie 22.
Die Battle Royale Map wurde endlich zerstört, also ein bisschen.
Das Stadion und die Berge in der Stadt sind zerstört von einem Untergrundbomb.
Die Bunker, die sich um die Map befinden, haben eine World War 2 Theme zu Overhaul, und
der ursprüngliche Gulag ist zurück.
Das Halloween Warzone Event ist auch auf der 19.
Überall ist das ein ziemlich großer Sendoff für die Cold War Integration mit Warzone.
Call of Duty Vanguard wird mit der Battle Royale nach dem Launch integriert und bringt
eine komplett neue Map mit.
A new rumor floating around says Konami is working on new Metal Gear Castlevania and Silent
Hill games.
Sounds like they're doing either a remake of Metal Gear Solid 3 or a direct follow up
to that particular title.
The Castlevania game sounds like a reboot for the franchise, so there's no telling what
it might end up being.
Where things get interesting is Silent Hill.
Konami is allegedly working on multiple new titles in the franchise and one has been outsourced
to a...
Aber dieses Game ist ja nie rausgekommen.
Das wollte er ja machen und dann hat Konami keinen Bock mehr gehabt und dann hat er Death
Stranding gemacht.
Hast du die Hausnummer bestellt, ja bei Aliexpress?
Was heißt denn Rave Reviews?
Rave Reviews untertrogen einfach, ja genau, das wird's bestimmt sein.
Ja, die China-Chinesen gehen wieder ab, mit History haben's die Chinesen eh nicht so,
weil da müsste man vielleicht auch ein paar Dinge ansprechen, die auch gerade in der
China-Chinesischen Historie vielleicht nicht ganz so geil gewesen sind, das mögen die
aber nicht.
Rave Reviews untertrogen einfach, ja genau, das wird's bestimmt sein.
Okay, du darfst weder gut noch evil sein, du darfst einfach nur für die Partei sein,
sonst darfst du nix in China wahrscheinlich.
Es gibt in China nicht gut oder böse, es gibt in China nur noch richtig oder falsch.
Richtig ist, wenn du das willst und das machst und das glaubst und das super findest, was
der ober-China-Chinese sagt und alles andere ist falsch, deswegen wird das jetzt gebannt.
Das ist natürlich auch eine gute Taktik.
Buying up studios, they just acquired Demon's Souls Remake Studio Bluepoint Games and have
their sights set on other studios as well.
The biggest players in the game like Microsoft, Sony, Epic, Tencent and others have been on
a spending spree in the past two years, gobbling up any studio looking for a buyout.
And while the acquisitions are tapering off this year, it's clear the industry is consolidating
around the major publishers.
EA have added four new titles to Nvidia's GeForce Now game streaming service.
Dragon Age Inquisition, Mirror's Edge Catalyst, Battlefield 1 and Unravel 2 are all available
on any device supported by the service.
Technically, that means you can now play a full on Battlefield game on your phone and
while game streaming is still a relatively niche way of playing, it's improved dramatically
over the past few years.
Aside from bandwidth requirements and latency issues, game streaming is now nearly indistinguishable
from running it on local hardware.
Development around PC, they're aiming for a 50 v 50 split of revenue between PC and console
platforms.
That means their console exclusive titles like Monster Hunter Rise will be getting PC
releases.
That also means no more timed console exclusives in the future.
Apparently, they're changing things up thanks to record sales of Resident Evil and the PC
release of Monster Hunter Rise.
Ich glaube, ohne scheiß Resident, das aktuelle Resident Evil, ich glaube das war wirklich
eines der gefundensten Fressen für Rule 34 im Internet.
Ich glaube die Leute, die sind ja da schon, die sind ja auf große Vampirfrau, sind die
ja schon, als der erste Trailer am Start war, sind die alle da drauf gesprungen.
Ich glaube, das war wirklich ein gefundenes Fressen fürs Internet.
Also ich wollte mal wirklich erzählen, das Ding läuft mit 120 FPS auf der Konsole super,
hat aber Probleme auf dem PC ordentlich zu laufen.
Daub das am Start hier, da habe ich so meine Zweifel dran.
X, genau.
Jawoll, schön Solo-Questen in einem MRO.
Das ist halt genau, das ist halt genau das andere Beispiel zu, weil wir es vorhin von
New World hatten.
Das ist halt genau der andere Ansatz.
Nur das ist glaube ich für die Leute, die das mögen, wirklich somit das Beste ist und
die werden halt in New World nicht glücklich.
Eher so ist was für Singleplayer-Spieler, die chatten wollen dabei.
Aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen, vorher haben sie erstmal das GTA 4 Remake-Projekt von GitHub
hart runtergestrikt.
Dieses Mal hat uns Levelcap gar nicht so sehr debatet, hat sogar ein bisschen Inhalt gehabt.
Nein, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an, uns ja noch an.
Mal kurz refreshen, vielleicht empfiehlt uns YouTube noch was Gutes.
Ja, das ist ja schon uralt, Story.
So, was können wir uns jetzt noch angucken?
PC am Straßenrand gefunden, wer wirft sowas weg?
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Jetzt haben wir sonst noch zur Auswahl Battlefield 3, Root Kid, Yoshi's Island, Sony, was auch
immer.
Ich habe doch relativ viel gefunden, für das das YouTube mir nichts vorschlägt, das
muss man sagen.
PC, aber der Titel irgendwie spricht damit an, wahrscheinlich ist es voll G-Bate und
er hat seinen eigenen Rechner an den Straßenrand gestellt und hat ihn dann wieder mit in die
Wohnung genommen oder so.
Hast du noch was mit CSGO am Hut?
Ich gucke ab und zu, aber selbst spiele ich nicht mehr.
Wo sind wir hier, Timos Hardware Haus, habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Der ist ganz schön sauber für das, dass der eine Weile am Straßenrand stand.
Okay, vielleicht hat der Typ rausgetragen auf die Straße, er ist zufällig vorbeigekommen
und hat gesagt, alle, ich nehme mit.
Die Leute, die meine Instagram Story gesehen haben, die wissen vielleicht, dass das Ganze
neben einem Müllcontainer stand, der am Rand einer Straße war, also ist diese Beschreibung
an der Straße schon ziemlich genau und als ich den dort gesehen habe, der ist ja gar
nicht so alt und nee, das ist er tatsächlich nicht, ihr seht ja auch schon rechts unten
den Interdorfkleber, der ist wirklich gar nicht so alt und ich bin sehr gespannt, ob
der PC noch funktioniert und warum er eigentlich weggeworfen wurde, weil ich würde sowas lieber
verkaufen, anstatt wegzuwerfen.
Mich würde interessieren, ob der Typ seine Festplatte vorher gelöscht hat oder ob er
einer drin ist.
Bevor wir aber mit dem Video beginnen, würde ich mich nochmal ganz herzlich für die 2000
Abonnenten bedanken, das ist wirklich richtig, richtig krass.
Ich schaue noch, ob ich da irgendein Special oder so hin bekomme, mal gucken, aber wirklich
vielen, vielen, vielen Dank.
So, kommen wir auch schon zum PC und ja, wie gesagt, ich habe hier das Ganze draußen gemacht,
weil der PC wirklich super, super eklig und dreckig ist.
Echt, der sieht gar nicht so dreckig aus.
Ich werde gleich sehen, wenn ich den aufmache, weil ich habe schon mal oben so reingeguckt
ein bisschen und das sieht echt nicht so schön da drin aus.
Unten rechts sieht man auch ein Intel Core i3 Aufkleber, ja.
Schade leider kein i5 oder i7, aber immerhin, ähm, zumindest wahrscheinlich ab vierter
Generation mal schauen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also für, für umsonst kann man das durchaus qualm lassen.
Ah, sehr interessant.
Was die Ports auf der Rückseite angeht, haben wir einmal PS2, 6x7, einmal DVI, VGA und HDMI,
einmal LAN, die ganzen Audioports und die Grafikkarte, wie man schon so gut verdisplayt
hat.
Guck mal, der hat sogar schon, nee, das ist es.
...Port HDMI und DVI.
Ja, aber ich kann sagen, Displayport hast du, also es sieht jetzt, guck mal, das ist sogar
eine doppelte Grafikkarte, das ist ganz so scheiße, kann das gar nicht sein, was da
drin steckt.
Doppel-Slot-Grafikkarte.
Das heißt, die wird auch nicht so alt sein und unten haben wir noch einen Standard-Netzteil,
was ich jetzt nicht wirklich zuordnen kann.
Sogar einen optischen Ausgang, das Mainboard ist auch nicht der größte Schrott.
Hier seht ihr einmal ganz kurz, wie unglaublich eklig dieser PC einfach ist.
Das, was ihr hier seht, klebt tatsächlich.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist und ich will es auch gar nicht anfassen.
Das ist einmal hier, das ist auch auf der Oberseite und das ist echt nicht schön, aber
wir machen den PC jetzt einfach mal auf und gucken mal, wie es innen aussieht, weil es
nicht sehr schön aussieht.
Die Seitenwand des PCs ist zum Glück mit zwei Schrauben befestigt, die man mit der Hand
abdrehen kann, das ist sehr angenehm und beim Aufschrauben zeigt sich auch schon, was ist
denn das für ein Go?
Cool Master.
Auch echt schwer ist, wie man hier auch schon erkennen kann, sehr schön aussieht.
Die Seitenwand des PCs ist zum Glück mit zwei Schrauben befestigt, die man mit der Hand
abdrehen kann, das ist sehr angenehm und beim Aufschrauben zeigt sich auch schon, was ist
denn das für ein Go?
Das ist bestimmt LC-Power China Netzteil.
Ja, er ist wirklich ziemlich staub.
Nee, das ist Silverstone Netzteil, kein LC-Power China Abfackel Netzteil, aber die Festplatte
ist noch drin.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob da jetzt noch was drauf ist.
Ich glaube, die Kabel gehen noch, wir waren komplett innen rum, ich weiß nicht, Kabelmanagement
gibt es da anscheinend nicht, wobei ich sagen muss, dass das bei einem Gehäuse auch echt
schwer ist.
Wie man hier auch schon erkennen kann, ist auch noch eine Festplatte im System verbaut.
Das Netzteil ist von Silverstone und hat oben komische Punkte drauf, es ist ebenfalls eine
Zwei-Lüfter-Grafikkarte verbaut, ein Intel Stockkühler, zwei RAM-Riegel, ein CD-Dotwerk
und noch zwei Gehäuse-Lüfter.
Also mal gucken, was das wird.
Hier sieht man auch noch mal ganz kurz, ich glaube, das ist als Lüfter da schon wirklich
viel Staub dran, auch an den Kabeln.
Ich bin mir sicher, das kann man alles reinigen, aber ob der PC noch funktioniert, das weiß
ich nicht.
Es könnte tatsächlich sein, dass irgendwelche Komponenten schon Schaden genommen haben,
aber ich hoffe einfach mal, bei der Festplatte spielt sich das aus.
Das ist eine Toshiba 1TB Festplatte, zwar noch nix, das ist alles trocken, der SSD ist
leider aber nicht verbaut, nur eine Festplatte, aber trotzdem cool.
Hier sieht man einmal das Silverstone-Netzteil, das hat wirklich komische Punkte oben drauf
und ist auch sehr staubig, aber das muss nicht zwingend heißen, dass es kaputt ist, aber
bei Netzteilen...
Ist das Netzteil falsch rum?
Ne.
...dann würde ich sowieso immer etwas aufpassen.
Die Grafikkarte, wie sie sich rausstellt, ist eine Radeon R9 270, das heißt, gar nicht
mal so alt, würde ich sagen, klar, schon etwas älter, aber mit der kann man heutzutage auch
noch was machen.
Es ist eine 2GB-Karte und ist natürlich, wie man hier auch schon erkennen kann, sehr staubig,
aber mal gucken, ob wir das reinigen können.
Der Prozessorlüfter ist, wie man sieht, auch sehr mit Staub zugesetzt, aber das sollte
man reinigen können.
11 Jahre, ich hab keine Ahnung, Alter, uah!
Das ist auf der Unterseite der Staubfilter, der ist wirklich komplett zugesetzt mit Staub,
wie man hier mal kurz sehen kann, also...
Ja, der Staubfilter macht das, wofür er da ist, Staubfilter.
Ich würde aber mal sagen, ich werde den PC später erst testen, ich werde erst mal alle
Komponenten sauber machen und die neu zusammenbauen, da ich echt Angst hab, dass ich mir jetzt
den Schalter irgendwas kaputt machen kann.
Ehrenfilter, Staubfilter MVP.
Deswegen werde ich jetzt erst mal alle Komponenten aus dem PC rausbauen.
Der Staubfilter macht das, was er soll.
Und die Komponenten mal vorstellen, also was, was ist, und danach werde ich den PC wieder
zusammenbauen und dann werden wir ihn testen, ob er noch funktioniert.
Angefangen hier mit der Radeon R9 270 von PowerColor, die sieht eigentlich noch ziemlich gut intakt
aus.
Und hier seht ihr die mal einmal ganz kurz, also sieht noch sehr schick aus, aber natürlich
sehr staubig, aber das kann man ja reinigen.
Als ich aber die Rückseite der Karte gesehen habe, habe ich mir schon ein bisschen Sorgen
gemacht, weil das war nicht nur Dreck, das war auch feucht und das ist natürlich dann
nicht so gut.
Klar, wenn die Grafikkarte nicht so betrieben wird, an Strom angeschlossen wird, sollte
das noch okay sein, aber ich hoffe mal, ich kriege das überhaupt gereinigt, weil das
war schon wirklich sehr fest gesetzter Staub.
Als nächstes habe ich mich dem Mainboard gewidmet, das ist übrigens ein ASRock W85M
Pro 4, für den Sockel 1150, das Rausbauen hat etwas gedauert, weil wegen den ganzen
Kabeln, aber am Ende seht ihr das mal ganz kurz hier, ist wie gesagt auch sehr staubig,
aber sieht trotzdem noch ziemlich gut aus.
Das sieht allgemein jetzt alles noch ziemlich gut intakt aus.
Das sind zwei Crucial RAM-Riegel mit jeweils 4GB DDR3, sprich wir haben 8GB, das geht doch
eigentlich.
Da kannst du sogar Windows 11 drauf laufen lassen.
Eigentlich auch ganz okay ist.
Beim Abnehmen des CPU-Kühlers und Reinigen der wirklich vertrockneten Wärmleitpaste,
zeigt sich ein Intel Core i3 4150, ja ist eine Einsteiger Core i3 CPU der vierten Generation,
wie gesagt leider kein i5, aber trotzdem für einen weggeworfenen PC, doch ganz okay.
Ja, jetzt kommen wir zum Teil, der mich echt auch ein bisschen angewidert hat, und zwar
das Gehäuse bzw. die restlichen Konetten daraus, sind halt Fussel, weil wie man hier auch mal
ganz kurz seht, einmal den Sauger genommen und gesaugt, Staubklumpen hinten drin, von
einer Größe, die habe ich auch noch nicht gesehen vorher, also das ist wirklich schon
sehr sehr extrem, und Mundschutz aufziehen, der Festplatte war wirklich ziemlich einfach,
und hier nochmal kurz, das ist eine Toshiba 1TB Festplatte mit 7200 RPM, also eine ganz
normale, die SSD, die da war bestimmt ursprünglich eine SSD Tränen, die hat der Typ ausgebaut
in neuen Rechner gepackt, Desktop, 1TB Festplatte, sehr gut, aber wie gesagt leider ohne SSD
im System.
Als ich die Vorderwand des Gehäuses abgenommen habe, habe ich erst mal diesen unglaublichen
Staub gesehen, der sich da angesammelt hat an den Lüftern, das war ja wirklich komplett
zugesetzt, aber zum Glück kann man das reinigen, es ist nur sehr eklig.
Es ist halt ein Staubfilter, der filtert halt ein paar Jahre und dann sieht er so aus.
Es ist jetzt alles auseinandergebaut, ich habe alles hier mal auf den Tisch ausgebreitet,
und ich werde jetzt anfangen das einzeln sauber zu machen, und da werde ich auch wieder
reingehen und dann den PC wieder zusammenbauen und testen.
Bei der Grafikkarte habe ich erst angefangen die Schutzkappe für den Crossfire-Connector
abzumachen, dann habe ich die vier Schrauben gelöst, und dann konnte man die Grafikkarte
auch schon relativ einfach auseinandernehmen.
Als nächstes habe ich die Wärmelightpasta bei der Grafikkarte abgewischt, das geht gar
nicht lang, es gibt nur eine halbe Minute.
Ich habe auch noch alle anderen Komponenten gereinigt, mit verschiedenen Mitteln, auch
mit ein bisschen Druckluft, das habe ich jetzt nicht alles aufgenommen, deswegen skippen
wir jetzt direkt nach innen und ich stelle euch alle Komponenten mal vor, wie sie komplett
gereinigt sind.
Ja, ich habe hier alle Komponenten einfach mal auf den Tisch gelegt und ich bin mit dem
Endergebnis echt zufrieden, wenn man mal bedenkt, wie unglaublich dreckig das Ganze war, besonders
die Grafikkarte ist wirklich sehr, sehr sauber.
Das sieht ja schon wieder wie geleckt aus.
Das Mainboard kann sich sehen lassen, es sieht wirklich wieder sehr, sehr gut aus, ich habe
wirklich darauf geachtet, dass ich den meisten Staub da weg bekomme, beim Netzteil habe ich
leider diese Punkte, die da oben drauf waren, nicht wirklich wegbekommen, ich habe es zwar
wirklich versucht, aber es ging einfach nicht.
Ne, das ist kein Schimmel.
Wahrscheinlich ist einfach hier oben die Farbe, oder irgendwie, ost, ost, ja, ach was, YOLO.
Ja, das funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut, die Werte sind alle ganz okay, der Power-Supply-Tester,
der meckert auch nicht rum, das heißt, das Netzteil werde ich jetzt erstmal so verbauen.
Anfang für den Zusammenbau werde ich jetzt erstmal die Vorderwand, erstmal den Casher
Hochdruck rein, ich habe hier geholtes Gehäuse ausgesprayt, dann kommt das DVD-Laufwerk rein,
was natürlich auch festgeschraubt wird, dann kommt das Netzteil rein, was ich jetzt wie
gesagt einfach weiter verwende, wenn es dann irgendwann nicht mehr funktioniert, baue
ich halt ein anderes ein, und als nächstes kommt das Mainboard, hierzu tue ich aber erst
die CPU in den Sockel, tue Wärmelattpaste drauf, installiere den CPU-Kühler und baue
das Ganze in das Gehäuse und schraube es so fest.
Als nächstes kommen die 2x4GB von Crucial in die RAM-Slots rein und dann wird die Festplatte
verbaut, die übrigens die Schrauben zur Befestigung unten hat, bzw. das Gestell, in dem die Festplatte
drin sind.
Normalerweise hängt ja hier noch sowas, aber da ist alles raus, ich meine das hier musst
du raus machen, wenn du so eine super mega ultra lange Grafikkarte hast.
Vor der Komponente her, natürlich fehlt die Grafikkarte noch, das Problem ist jetzt,
jetzt muss ich das ganze Kabel managen und das ist bei dem Gehäuse echt echt schwer,
ob ihr es glaubt oder nicht.
Ach was, Kabelmanagement, wer braucht Kabelmanagement, einfach reinstopfen, zumachen und nie wieder
angucken.
Hier, ja es sieht eigentlich echt nicht gut aus, ich weiß, aber es ist wirklich mega
schwer, weil hinten null Platz ist bei diesem Gehäuse, auch wenn da so eine kleine Wölbung
ist, das geht wirklich nicht und die Anschlüsse des Mainboards und bzw. die Löcher des Gehäuses
sind wirklich nicht dazu gemacht.
Einfach reinstecken, zumachen und nie wieder reingucken.
Ich werde jetzt noch die Grafikkarte reinbauen und dann die Seitenwände drauf machen und
dann sieht das ganze hoffentlich auch schon etwas besser aus.
Bevor ich allerdings die Grafikkarte reinbaue, muss ich natürlich auch hier Wärmeleitpasta
auftragen und natürlich den Lüfter bzw. den Kühler wieder drauf tun.
Ja, das ist jetzt mein finales Endergebnis, ich habe auch die Seitenwand hinten drauf
getan und die Grafikkarte ist auch drin.
Es sieht schon nicht mehr ganz so schlimm aus, natürlich die Kabel links, besonders
der Lüfter links, der hat ein Kabel, was genau dort aus dem Mainboard auch angeschlossen
werden muss, das heißt, ich habe das jetzt unter der Grafikkarte hergeführt, das gleiche
gilt auch fürs Audiokabel, das ist jetzt so vorne links bei dieser Lücke, bei der Grafikkarte
geht das unten durch.
Klasse.
Ja, die Karte hängt irgendwie ein bisschen runter hier hinten, das könnte vielleicht
sein, dass das hinten im PCIe-Express-Slot dieses Einrast-Ding nicht mehr richtig funktioniert.
Ja, die Karte hängt ein bisschen runter.
Ein bisschen umständlich gemacht, aber es sieht nicht mehr so schlimm aus, außerdem
Leute, der PC hat eine Seitenwand, wo man nicht durchgucken kann, also beschwer ich mich
nicht.
Mach zu und mach an.
Als letztes noch die Seitenwand drauf und den Staubfilter wieder rein.
Und schon ist der PC theoretisch gesehen betriebsklar.
Der geht.
Und ich habe ihn ja noch nicht getestet.
Jetzt kommt der große Moment.
Der geht.
Das muss ich zeigen.
Ja, der Rechner geht an und tatsächlich kommt auch Bild, das hat mich schon wirklich sehr
gefreut, weil ganz ehrlich, der Rechner hätte auch ganz gut gar nicht mehr funktionieren
können, so nass und dreckig wie der war und gestartet hat dann tatsächlich Windows 10
und das hat auch ziemlich lange gebraucht.
Moment, der hat wirklich seine Betriebssystemplatte da drin gelassen?
Alter, ich habe gedacht, das war eine SSD, die hat der alte Besitzer rausgeschmissen,
das alte drin gelassen.
Okay, dann doch nicht, richtig Pepega-Typ wieder.
Ja, also der alte Besitzer.
Oh Gott, die Leute sind so blöd.
Mhm, natürlich setzt er das gleich zurück, alles klar, alles klar.
Ich oute mich jetzt einfach mal, ich würde es nicht gleich zurücksetzen, sondern erst
mal gucken, was der Typ da so drauf hat, weil ich neugierig bin.
Natürlich mein USB-C geschnappt, habe Windows 10 installiert, das hat auch ohne Probleme
funktioniert und am Ende waren wir dann hier auf dem Desktop ganz frisch installiert.
Natürlich, wie man hier sehen kann, noch ohne Grafiktreiber und die werde ich jetzt
mal installieren und so sieht das Ganze mit Grafiktreiber aus, ich habe jetzt noch ein
schönes hinteren Bild reingetan.
Hier sieht man noch mal kurz, was genau verbaut ist, wie gesagt ein Intel Core i3-4150 mit
3,5 Gigahertz, 8GB RAM, eine R9 270, auf der Straße gefunden, kann man das nehmen.
Also ich jetzt definitiv nicht mitgenommen, ich habe eh schon so viel alten Shit hier
rumliegen, aber wenn man einen Rechner braucht, warum nicht, das ist schon in Ordnung, der
Rechner ist jetzt fertig.
Also ich jetzt nicht mitgenommen.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, warum man sowas wegschmeißen würde, klar ich kann
es verstehen, weil es irgendwo lange rum stand, weil es total versifft ist, es irgendwie
loswerden will, aber dann kann man es doch auch theoretisch für wenig Geld auf Kleinanzeigen
stellen oder so, aber klar.
Ne, das wäre mir den Stress nicht wert, mit wasletzte Preisleuten da zu reden.
Ich würde das wahrscheinlich aufs Dachboden stellen, so wie ich es mit meinem, wenn ich
einen neuen Rechner kaufe, mit dem ich aktuell auch machen werde.
Für mich ist das natürlich jetzt ein guter Fund und ich habe jetzt einen schönen funktionären
PC, mit dem ich irgendwas machen kann, vielleicht noch verkaufen.
Der PC sieht wirklich wieder sehr gut aus und schreibt mir doch mal in die Kommentare,
würdet ihr den PC einfach so entsorgen?
Ich nicht auf jeden Fall.
Ja, das war es auch schon mit dem Video.
Achso, ne, entsorgen nicht, aber ich würde ihn nicht mitnehmen.
Falls es euch gefallen hat, würde ich mich sehr gerne über eine Bewertung oder ein Abo
freuen und dann würde ich sagen, bis zum nächsten Video.
Tschüss.
Bist du dieser 40er?
Ich bin nicht 40.
Leute, eigentlich müsste ich jetzt mal was futtern, ich habe übelst Hunger, ich bin
schon 3 Stunden 12 on und nachher muss ich mit dem Fabian spielen wir weiter Diablo 2,
aber ohne Stream.
Kennst du das?
Ja, das kenne ich.
Irgendwas Spannendes, was wir gucken.
Ich bookmarken mir das jetzt einfach, Bam, Bookmark, Session, New Folder, 03102021, save.
Wann kommt denn das Video mit dem ehemaligen Azubi, naja, ihr hättet es euch wahrscheinlich
schon denken können.
Ich habe ja gesagt, ich schneide, ich muss das Video am Wochenende noch schneiden.
Was meint ihr, Chet, habe ich das Video gestern geschnitten?
Nein, habe ich nicht gemacht, ich habe gestern den Heiz-Champ fertig gemacht, meine Heizung
im Keller kann ich jetzt über meine Home Assistant steuern.
Off Stream habe ich das fertig programmiert, da war ich ein bisschen schneller.
Ja wie, ja ganz fertig ist es noch nicht, ist der Frasier eigentlich on, da ist er,
der Fabian mit seinen Weep Games, weiß nicht, ob ich ihn haust, das letzte Mal, dass ich
beschwert, dass ich ihn gehorstet habe, komm wir hausten den Fabian, auf geht's.
Raiden, raiden, ich raide ihn, Leute wir sehen uns, ich gehe jetzt was essen, ich habe übelst
Hunger und ich kaufe mir keine Gucci Cap, könnt ihr mal bei ihm vorbeigucken, ein paar
sinnlose Emotes spammen und wenn Weep Games nichts für euch sind, euch dann was anderes
suchen.
Also, ich futter jetzt China Ente mit Erdnusssauce, ich habe nämlich extra doppelte Portionen
bestellt, da ich noch eine übrig habe, also bis denn, machts gut, CU.